welcome to simply learn and matplot
library my name is richard kirschner
with the simply learn team that's
www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead today we're
going to study the matte plot library
and the python code so let's start with
what is matplot library map plot library
is an open source drawing library which
supports rich drawing types it is used
to draw 2d and 3d graphics
and there are so many packages in the
matplot library we're going to cover the
basics and there are so many packages
that sit on top of the map flight
library that we can't even cover them
all today but we'll hit the main one so
you have a good understanding of what
the matplot library is and what the
basics can do you can understand your
data easily by visualizing it with the
help of matplot library you can generate
plots histograms bar charts and many
other charts with just a few lines of
code and here we have some basic types
of plots you can see here that we'll go
into we have the bar chart the histogram
boy i use a lot of histograms in my
stuff scatter plot line chart pie chart
and area graph
let's start plotting them and to do this
i'm going to be using jupiter notebook
you can use any of your python
interfaces for programming or scripting
and running it of course we here really
like the jupiter notebook for doing
basic a lot of basic stuff because it's
so visual
and in our jupyter notebook which opens
up in this case i'm using google chrome
you can go up here to new and we'll
create a new python 3 and set that up
if you're not familiar with jupyter
notebook we do have a tutorial that
covers some of the basics of that you'll
look at any of our tutorials i usually
cover a number of them showing how to
set up jupiter and anaconda i myself use
jupiter through anaconda in fact let's
go ahead and open that up and just take
a look at see what that looks like you
can see your anaconda navigator if you
install it it will automatically install
the jupyter notebook and that also
installs a lot of other things i know
some people like the qt console for
doing python or spyder i've never used
them i actually use notepad plus plus as
one of my editors and then i use the
jupiter notebook a lot because it's so
easy to have a visual while i'm
programming an even simple script in
python i'll take it from the jupyter
notebook and then do a save as you know
it's go under file and you can download
as a python program so that will
download it as an actual python versus
the ipython that this saves it as
so let's go ahead and dive in and see we
got going here and let's go ahead and
put matplot library tutorial and i'm
going to turn this cell into a mark down
so it doesn't actually run it
you can see it has a nice little title
there that's all jupiter notebook
and then from matplot library
let's import
pi lab
back one and then let's go ahead and
just print
we'll go pi lab
and the version let's go ahead and run
this so we're going to import our pi lab
module from the matplot library and we
find out the word version 1.15.1
always important to note the version
you're in probably i was reading an
article that said the number one thing
that python programmers struggle with is
remembering what version they're working
in and making sure that they're going
from one platform to the other with the
same version and if we're going to graph
things i think we need some data to
graph so we're going to import numpy as
np now if you're not familiar with numpy
definitely go back and check out our
numpy tutorial there's so many different
things you can do with it dealing with
reshaping the data and creating the data
we're just going to use it to create
some data for us and there is a lot of
ways to create data but we're going to
use the np.line space
so we're going to create a numpy array
and the way you read this is we're going
to create numbers between 0 and 10 and
we're going to create 25 of these
numbers we're just going to divide that
equally up between 0 and 10. and if we
have x coordinates we should probably
have some y coordinates and we'll do
something simple like x times x
plus 2. and let's just take a look we're
going to print x
and print
y
let me go ahead and run this
and let's see what we got going on here
so we have our x coordinates which is 0
0.4 0.83 etc and you can look at this as
an xy plot so we have zero we have two
we have point four one six we have two
point one seven and just as a quick
reminder we're gonna do print np array x
comma y dot reshape 25 comma 2. and the
reason i want to do this is i want to
show you something here
a lot of times a program returns
x comma y and it's an array of x comma y
x comma y x comma y
and so when you're working with the pie
plot
you have to separate it out and reshape
it so if i start off with pairs like
this i can reshape them if i know
there's 25 pairs in there i can switch
the 2 and the 25 and this is kind of
goofy but we'll do it anyways reshape so
i'm going to reshape my 25 by 2 back to
2 by 25
and if i run that you'll see i end up
with the same output as the x y the two
different arrays in here
and this is important that we want x and
y separate
again that's all numpy stuff but it's
important to understand that this is a
format that matplot library works with
it works with an array of x's and they
should match your array of y's so each
one has 25 different entities in it
and then for our basic plotting of this
data it only takes one command to draw
graph of this data and so we use our
from up here where we imported pi lab we
take our pi lab and the key net under
there is plot for plotting a line and
then we want our x coordinates and our y
coordinates and we'll throw in r and the
r simply means red so we're going to
draw the line in red let me go and run
that
you can actually switch this around if
you wanted to do different there's b
for blue we have a lot of fun yellow
hard to see yellow there we go but we'll
go ahead and stick with red
run
and when you're doing presentations with
these try to be consistent you know if
the business and the shareholders send
you a
spreadsheet and they have losses in red
use red for losses in your graph
try to be consistent use green for
profit for money you don't have to
necessarily use green but it's whatever
they're using whatever the company's
using try to mirror that that way people
aren't going to be confused if you
switch your data around every time one
graph has red for loss and one graph has
blue for loss it gets really confusing
so make sure you're consistent in your
graphs and your coloring and something
to know because we're going to cover
this in a minute this is your canvas
size so we have a canvas here and what
we're going to do next is we're going to
look at sub graphs okay
so let's take our pi lab and create a
sub
plot
and one of the things also to know when
we're working with the
matplot library i'm not setting when i
do this this is my drawing canvas the pi
lab so once i've imported the pi lab i'm
drawing my images on there very
important to know and with the subplot
we're going to give it some different
values
and we're going to represent by rows
columns and indexes and let's do one two
one so it's going to be the first row
second column and the index is like you
can stack your graphs and things like
that we don't worry too much about
indexes but rows and columns we want to
go ahead and use row one and column two
and if we're going to have one object we
should probably have two but before we
do that we have to
plot data onto the subplot so the order
is very important and we're going to
stick with our x comma y and let's do
this we're going to add in
a third parameter here remember we did
red we're going to add shorthand dash
dash for dashed lines so this plots the
data into row 1 column
and if we're gonna do that let's do up
another one pi
lab.subplot and if we're gonna do row
one let's do
column two and index two
and this time we're gonna add g for
green and this denotes a style and if
we're going to set up our pi lab
subplot there we go right lab we've got
to go ahead and plot that pi
lab plot
and instead of x y we want y comma x
oops i messed up this is in the wrong
spot there we go we'll move that down
here real quick because that goes in the
plot part so the subplot tells it the
row column and index and the pi plot
tells it what data in this case we
switch them and the color and then the
style shorthand now let's go ahead and
run that
and you'll see it takes this canvas
splits it in two and now we have two
different graphs and we have the red one
with dashed lines and we have the green
one which is has a little stars going up
and if we take this and let's just um
just for fun let's change this and run
that with an index of one it puts them
both on the same index and also gives me
a warning because it's a strange way of
doing two subplots there's depreciated
there's another way to do it but most
people just ignore that warning because
it's not going to go away anytime soon
now that's using the same setup what
happens if we do instead of
this let's change the column on here and
find out what happens
and if we do the column
it didn't really like that on the setup
it just disappears so let's keep our
column as 2 and let's change the row on
the second one to 2
and run that
and you'll see again it kind of squishes
everything together and causes some
issues so let's take the index so these
need a unique index and you can see here
where i made some changes i said row two
and look what happens when i change to
column two so i now have row two column
two index two i squished it up here so
you could put another graph underneath
is what that does and there's all kinds
of different things you really have to
just play with these numbers till you
get a handle on them because
you know we have to repeat it 164 times
according to cambridge university if
it's completely new to you and you can
see right here where we go three run
there we go but you can see it takes a
little bit sometimes to play with these
and get the numbers right i hope they
hit the wrong one that's why let's go
three there three there run
there we go now it's overlapping so i
have this doubled over here on the right
for now we'll just go ahead and leave
this with the
where we have column and row two and the
two different indexes so they appear
nice and neatly side by side
and then as we just saw as we were
flashing through them we can put them on
top of each other
and let me just highlight that and copy
it down here
paste it down there and here we have one
two one and then we'll do one two one
also for this one and that puts the two
subplots directly on top of each other
gives us that warning and you can see we
now have two different sets of data
graphed on top of each other and you can
also see how it did the indexes since
one of them is from 0 to 10 that's the
green one on the x axis and the other
one is from 0 to 10 on the y axis so it
took the greatest value of either one
and then used those as a shared value
so let's
next look at operator description and
we'll go ahead and turn this cell into a
markdown and run that so it looks nice
so fig and you remember i talked about
the canvas earlier i briefly mentioned
it we're going to look a little bit more
at the canvas later on but that's what
the figure is fid we're going to add
axes so we're going to initialize the
subplot add the subplot
in rows and columns and all kinds of
different things with this you can do
let's look at that code and see exactly
what's going on and i want you to notice
that there's fig which is the actual
canvas in the matplot library and ax is
commonly used to refer to the subplots
so we're creating subplots you'll see ax
equals plt subplot
earlier we did the pi lab so let's go
ahead and import pi plot from matplot
library and we're going to do it as plt
you'll see that a lot that's really the
standard in the industry is to call it
plt just like pandas is pd and numpy
array is np certainly you can import it
as whatever you want but i would stick
to the standards and we're going to do
the same graph as we did above
with the pi lab but with the plt so if
it looks familiar there's reason we're
doing this because we want to show you
how the figure part works and working
with the canvas goes but we're going to
do the same plot as we did before and
we'll call it fig and we're going to set
that equal to plot figure so there's our
figure or canvas on there and let's
create a variable called axes and we're
going to set that equal to fig dot add
axes
and in this we're going to control the
left right the width the height of the
canvas from 0 to 1.
so we can go ahead and i'm just going to
put some stuff in there i got five point
one point eight point eight so when
you're looking at this this is a zero to
one or you could say fifty percent ten
percent eighty eighty percent but it's a
control it's going to control your left
and your right along with the width and
the height so the width and the height
we're to use 80 percent and we're going
to have like a little indent on the left
and the right and this should look
familiar from above x's dot plot
x comma y
and then let's give it a color how about
red since we're recreating the same
graph let's keep it uniform oops and it
helps if i use ax i s instead of ax es i
don't know where that came from but this
looks identical to the one we had up
above so here's our axis plot x comma y
of red
same graph same setup but this time
we've added a variable equal to the
figure dot add axes so our plot figures
our canvas our axes is what we're
working in and then our axis.plot x
comma y
and again we can draw sub graphs let me
put that down here
[Music]
just like we did before and a little
different notation here we have fig
comma
axes equal
plt.subplots
and in here it's going to be the number
of rows
we're going to do one row
and columns equals 2. so if you remember
before that's what we did we had one row
with two different graphs on it we're
going to do the same thing but know how
we did this here's our figure our canvas
and our axes we're going to create
actually two different axes we're going
to create row one column two and so axis
is an array of information so we can
simply do
four
let's do x in axes
this will now look familiar x dot plot
we're going to do x comma y we'll go
ahead and make a red
keep everything looking the same
remember nice uniform graphs everything
looks the same and if we go ahead and
run this
you'll see we get two nice side-by-side
graphs so just as we had before the same
look the same setup
and just for fun let's change in columns
to three we'll run that and now you see
we'll have three on there and let's see
if we make it a little bit more
interesting we'll do in rows equals to
two and you can see down here we're
going to get an attribute eric's is
trying to scrunch everything together
so it does have a limit how much stuff
you can put in one small space that's
important to know you can fix that by
changing the canvas size which we'll
look at in just a minute and there's
other ways to change it on here but here
we go we can do in rows two and columns
equals one you can see two nice images
right above each other we'll go back to
the original one row two columns side by
side left to right and
we can also
draw a picture or graph
inside another graph
and that's kind of a fun thing to do
it's important to note that we can layer
our stuff on top of each other which
makes for a really nice presentation
so let's start by uh fig let's create
another figure so we're going to start
over again with our canvas we set that
equal to plt.figure
[Music]
saying how big this axis is this figure
in the axes is so this is going to be
the big
axes and let's do axes 2 equals
another figure add axes and then
0.2.5.4.3
and if we're going to do this they need
data on them so let's go ahead and plot
some data on our axis so axis1 dot plot
and we'll make this simply x comma y
comma make it red and then let's go
axes2 dot plot and let's reverse them y
comma x comma green there we go doing
what i told you not to do you shouldn't
be swapping axes around and plotting
your data in five different directions
because it's confusing let's go ahead
and run this and see what this looks
like and then let's talk a little bit
about this we talked about the 0.2.5.4.3
and let me just grab the annotation for
that that's left right width and height
so we have in here that this is going to
be left right so here's our left is
point one in point five and we you know
what let's just play with this a little
bit what happens when i change this to
point one moves it way over to the left
so there's our point one so we can make
this point four run that there we go so
you can see how you can move it around
the branches on here 0.2
0.5 is the
left so that's our right so see what
happens when we do point oh let's make
this point one that actually is they had
it down at left right i thought this was
wrong it's actually how far from the
bottom let me switch that on here bottom
there we go so we had here on this we
can go ahead and put that back to 0.5
and run that and this is 0.3 let's make
this 0.3 also and that is the width and
then of course there's the height we can
make that really tight actually let's do
0.2
let's run that and you can see it
changes the height on there we make it
even smaller 0.2 by 8.2 and as you can
see you can get stuck playing with this
to make it look just right it can
sometimes take a little bit
certainly once you have the settings if
you're doing a presentation you try to
keep it uniform unless it doesn't make
sense for the graph you're working on
try to keep the same colors the same
position and the same look and feel
and i mentioned earlier we can adjust
the canvas size so this is from earlier
i just copied it down below we're going
to re-plot the same data we've been
looking at and what we can do is we can
change the figure size to 16 by nine let
me run that show you what that looks
like so it fills the whole screen and
then if you are normally when you're
working on the screen you don't worry
too much about this but we can set the
dpi
to 300
run that
there it goes this is your dots per inch
and if you are doing an output of this
and you're printing a hard copy you want
the higher quality i would suggest
nothing under 300 if it's a professional
print you might get a little less than
that but whenever i'm doing professional
graphics and printing them out on
something 300 dots per inch is kind of
the minimal on there you can go a lot
higher too but keep in mind the higher
you get the more memory it takes the
more lag time and the more resources you
use so usually 300 is a good solid
number to use your dots per inch and you
can see it drills a nice it draws a nice
large canvas here which is 16 by nine
and then the dpi is 300 on here it's a
little higher quality and just out of
curiosity i wonder how long it takes to
draw something double that size 600 and
you can see here where at 600 dpi it's
going to take a while there it goes just
because it's utilizing a lot more
graphics on there and let me just go
back to the 300 now we'll actually do
let's do a 100 you're not going to see a
difference on this because it is web
based graphics are pretty low
and up here you saw i did this with the
plot figure this works the same if i do
figure axes subplot figure size and then
we'll go ahead and do axes
dot plot
x comma y comma we'll stick to red
let's go ahead and run this and you
should get almost the same thing here
here's our or axis on the subplot on
here with the fixed size and the dpi let
me take this all out let me just remove
all that real quick run it again there
we go now we're back to our original
figure and let's look at some of the
other things you can do with this
one things we do is we can set a title
for the axis so axis set title you'll
see right here since i put this on the
axis it's the main title for the whole
graph
and if you're going to have a title you
should also label so we can label our x
label and we can set our y label in this
case we're just going to call it x and y
keep it nice and uniform and if we run
this you'll see that we've added a nice
x label and y label whoops where'd they
go and it turns out in this environment
that you have to put it before the title
so let me go ahead and put it before the
title and there's our x y and then we
run that and of course we can also do
upper size a little bit see what's going
on a little better so here we have x
label x if you come down here you'll see
our x label and our y label we can of
course change this to x
label you can change this to y
maybe whatever you want on here of
course and our title graph there we go
run so here we have our title graph our
y label and our x label all set up on
our nice little plot and then before we
move on to the next section let's do one
more thing on here we have a thing
called the legend and we're going to do
we're going to set our ax legend label 1
label 2 up here it's a format for it but
let's go down here and actually use it
i'm going to do two different plots
we're going to have axes plot x by x
times x squared and x cubed and if i run
this you'll see it puts two nice graphs
on the setup on there but it's nice to
have a legend telling you what's going
on so for the legend we can actually do
axes since we have the two plots legend
and on here we've created an array
and we have y equals x squared y equals
x cubed you can actually put this as
whatever you want those are just strings
and then location two and let's go ahead
and run this and see what that looks
like and you can see it puts a nice
legend on the upper left hand corner
location two we can do location three
and run it and it drops it down to the
bottom
location one i can't remember where
that's at there we go upper right so
each one of these is a number that
refers to the different locations on the
screen
have to play with them or look them up
to remember where they're at but they do
work it just kind of moves around
depending on where you want your legend
out on there so on this section we cover
the title of the graph the y labels and
legends this is we're getting into some
starting to look really fancy here so we
now have something we can actually put
out you'll see the title the graph looks
a little fuzzy so i might in a web setup
put the dpi up a couple notches maybe
put it at 200 100 might work fine just
so you know something to notice on here
when you're playing with these different
things we had our subplots dpi equals oh
let's do 200 to see what that looks like
so you can see now it's a lot clearer
it's also larger so it's a nice little
feature you can throw in there with your
dpi dots per inch
so the next section is let's look at
some graph features we're going to look
at line color transparency size and a
few more things on here and oops i
forgot the main title so we have our
figure and our axes equals our plot and
subplots and i'm going to do a dpi
equals 150 so the graph comes out nice
and large and easy for you to see
and let's go ahead and do three plots on
here we'll do x by x plus one so it's
just gonna be a straight line plot
x plus x plus two
and axis dot plot
x x plus three this looks like we're
doing nearest neighbor setup we're
showing how it uh located data and
putting your lines on there between the
nearest neighbors there we go so it
draws a nice little graph with three
lines on it one of the things we can do
is we can control the alpha on this oops
and you can actually see the um when
they did these lines it automatically
pulls in different colors for your setup
so there's some automatic automatic
things going on in there and a lot of
times we do that comma r but we're going
to do color equals red another notation
on here let's go ahead and run this now
we have a bright red line down there and
with the map plot library you're not
limited to red you can also use the one
of many different color references as
you see here with the pound sign one one
five dd which just is just blue and we
can do the same thing with another color
on here which it turns out to be green i
can just as easily do this green
blue oops there we go blue and run that
and you'll see here we have red blue and
green and what i want to do is i want to
make this we're going to say what's
called the alpha on this and we're going
to set this equal to 0.5
so this is halfway see-through when i
run this and it's almost going to look
pink because you can see through it and
let's change this just a little bit just
to make this kind of fun let's square it
there we go run it so now we have this
nice square that comes up and you can
see when it crosses it because i plotted
these two lines after it and they have
no alpha the red is behind those lines
or in this case pink because we did the
alpha halfway through so let's go ahead
and do this alpha equals 0.5 and oh you
know what instead of squaring it let's
take it to the 0.5 power that'll be kind
of interesting to see what that does
we'll just go to keep it squared there
we go and run that and let's go back and
look at this where it crosses over and
the first thing you see right here is on
the blue it's kind of light blue now you
can see how the two colors add together
you get almost a purple on there so i
can clearly see where the red cross is
the blue line and then the green just
blanks it over because i didn't do any
opaqueness no alpha on there so this is
great if you have lots of data that
crosses over and you need to be able to
track those lines better and we'll go
ahead and do this 0.5 and we'll run that
oops i did
equals 0.5 let me go ahead and run that
and so you can see right here now you
can easily see the red line how it
crosses the green and the blue down here
and if we want to we can do this as uh
the default is one solid so we can
change this all to point eight let me
just do that
oops 58 there we go
run
oops i must have hit a wrong button
there let me try that again i actually
get rid of a bracket and let's go ahead
and run that
and we come down here and look at this
you can still see where it passes behind
them but the green dominates and the
blue dominates because we're now at
eighty percent instead of fifty percent
when you can do less that's kind of fun
although at some point the lanes kind of
fade
so point five is usually the best
setting on there we have a nice pastel
here at point three and you can easily
see where they cross over and just like
you can play with the colors we can play
with line width and you know let's do
let's try dpi 100 and see what that
looks like on my screen equals 100 and
we'll go ahead and just take our ax plot
let's do four of these lines just you
can see how they look next to each other
real quick here there we go
and if i run this they should all appear
the same it automatically does different
colors on there so let's do color equals
blue
i forgot my quotation marks there we go
and we'll go ahead and just make these
all blue just for purposes of being nice
and uniform and then what i want to do
is i want to do the line width
width
equals
0.25 and let's just copy and paste that
down here
let's do equals one
about 1.5 and let's do one let's make
this equal to two let's see what that
looks like and we do that you can see it
goes from a very thin line a point five
a one are 1.5 and 2 which is twice the
width of the one and if we're going to
do different sizes we had different
colors we had our alpha scheme let's
take this whole thing here
let's paste it down here and do another
one
but instead of line width let's look at
styles and something to know here you
can actually abbreviate this with lw so
line width can also be point let's just
do everything point two and let's set up
a line style we'll do the first one
dashes let me just paste that down here
so i'm not doing a lot of extra typing
there we go
take this out so we have our dashed
we can do a dash dot we'll just do the
dash dot here and a colon here there we
go and there's a lot of different
options we'll look at a few more as we
go down for different ways of
highlighting data
but when you look at this we have
everything as a line width of two and
now we have a straight line we have a
dashed line or a dot dash and a dot dot
line
and then another thing we can add on
here is we're going to do here's our ax
plot and we did x let's do x plus
4 so it goes right on the top and do
color black line width 1.5 so it's a
smaller line
and we're going to take the line and
we're going to set dashes so look i've
changed some of the notation here for my
line and my ax plot so i can set my line
comma equal to x plot and then i can
change the line settings this way and
when i run this let me run that on here
you'll see the 5 10 15 10 creates a
series of dashes that are buried in link
link in this case they alternate between
a short dash and a long dash we can play
with these numbers curiosity always has
me what happens when you play with the
numbers just to see what they look like
let's do this let's paste this down here
i'll do two of these just because
they're kind of fun to play with and
let's change this from 10 to
3 and we're going to change this one
from 15
to
4. and let's run that
and you can see the differences in the
lines oops very a little bit confusing
on there because i forgot to change the
lines are all on top of each other so
let me change that really quick here and
let's run that and now you can see
here's our original dashed line
alternating when i change these numbers
on the second one the very end value to
three you can see now we have the dashes
of five let's see i'm going to guess
this is a dash is a five skip ten dashes
of 15 skip three and then it goes back
to the beginning dash is five dashes
skip 10 15 dashes skip three and of
course the last one we just switched up
a little bit it looks a lot more uniform
because i'm using two sets of ten or if
i did something like this and change it
to 30 it really becomes pronounced as
far as the distances between them and
instead of four let's go oh let's put 30
here also 30 by 30. there we go really
pronounced on that one and let's look at
one more important group for plotting
our data and in this we're going to
here's our plot we started with with the
x plus one x plus two x plus three and
did it in blue on this one's three or
four different blue lines
and this property we want to add the
actual plots so you can see where the
plots are on the graph and for that we
might have marker equals o and if we run
this you'll see it puts a dot for each
of these and there's 25 dots because we
have 25 x values so we actually have
zero and each of the different values of
x y are then plotted here with the dots
and we don't want to just limit
ourselves to dots
you can also do
plus sign that's another option dots is
most common i'll actually like the dots
the best if we do the plus sign you see
if it's a nice crosshairs or plus sign
on there and we can do a marker there's
a number of different markers you can
use
and i think this one was it s is another
one
which is a nice square and that's
actually a good one that's for square o
for
period okay that's just kind of weird so
you can see that probably on these
markers another one is the number one so
if we run that you'll see we now have
these little hatch marks
and let's take oh let's just go with the
o on this one
by the way this works with square really
nicely some of the stuff we're going to
do here on just a second let's do marker
size equals two and
change that to five and run that and you
can see here it's a nice little tiny dot
versus uh the size dot here and this is
interesting because it said two i
thought it would be bigger
but if you do 0.5 it gets even smaller
and let's just do 10 to see what that
looks like run that looks huge so marker
size a lot of these are dependent on the
dpi in the setup so there's things that
switch around as far as the way the size
shows up you got to be a little careful
when you change one setting it can
change all the other markers and then
let's take our square on here
and we'll do we had marker size so we
also have marker face
we'll set that equal to red of course we
need to take change the so it's up one
notch we'll run that whoops must have
mistyped something on here and i did
it's marker face color equals red and so
when i run that you can now see i have
the squares on there with the marker
face color of course we can mix and
match these
come down here and we'll make this
instead of let's make this plus seven
and we'll make this
size 15
marker face color
equals
and we'll do what green just because
there we go run very hard to actually
see what's going on there still 25 dots
they kind of overlap as you can see they
print them over each other of course if
we really wanted to make it look
horrible we could just make that really
huge generally though you want something
a little bit smaller and cuter we'll
just try doing it this way there we go
that's too small to even see the face so
four you can start to see the face on
there around four and maybe an eight
eight might be a good number for this
there we go eight again that all just
depends on what you're trying to show
and display so we've covered a lot of
stuff here as far as our lines we've
covered
opaque with our alpha setting on there
give us some nice pastels you can see
how they overlap and how they cross over
we covered the line with
different size on there different
formats for the line itself and these
are all you can combine all these so you
can have our line width equals two line
style equals dash you can bring this
down here also to the markers and then
we added markers in just entered a
circle a
plus sign the square a little tick which
uses a one
then we add a marker size and a marker
color face and we combine those you see
we get a nice different series of
representations we also briefly
mentioned color where you didn't have to
use like in here we used color black
some place up here and have to find it
we use the actual number for the color
as opposed to i changed them to red and
blue so you get very precise on the
color if you have a very specific color
set that you need to match your website
or whatever you're working on
all those are tools in the matplot
library so we have one more piece to
formatting the graph so we want to show
you and then we have two big sections
we're going to go over the different
graphs that they have along with a
challenge problem so let's go to the
last section we're going to look at is
limits we're going to limit our data
so this first primer is going to paste
in there we're going to create our
subplots one two so one row two columns
we're gonna do a figure size of ten
comma five this should all look familiar
now since we've done a number of them
and we're gonna go ahead and plot and
this is an interesting notation you
should notice here our axis zero so one
we've used instead of you can just
iterate through them but they're just an
array so it's an array of zero is still
the axes of the first axes out of two
and we're going to plot x
x squared
x
x cubed line with two so we're gonna go
ahead and just plot two graphs right on
top of each other without doing multiple
plots on here and we'll set the grid
equal to true one here let's go ahead
and run that
and you can see here our two plots with
the x value going across
and i'm gonna do something similar and
by the way as you can just if you look
at it you can see the grid on there
that's all that is easier to spot the
data going across we're going to take
the same data for axes one so we have
our plot of x x squared x and x cubed
line with 2
and this time we're going to take our
axis 1 and do y limit
it's actually set underscore y limit
this is the y axis so it's going to be
an array of two two values and we'll do
0 comma 60 i'm just making these numbers
up the guys in the back actually made
them up i'm just using their numbers
we're going to set the x limit
and we'll set the x limit as um don't
forget our brackets there
two comma five
so it's the same data going in and but
we're setting a limit on it let's go
ahead and run that and let's see what it
comes out of and here we have the y
limit zero to sixty so we're looking at
just the lower part of this curve here
up to here and we have the x limit two
to five so that starts right here at two
and you can see very different graphs
this is kind of nice because you could
actually put one of these on top of the
other if you wanted to draw focus to one
part of a graph
remember how we did that earlier one
inside the other but just a quick note
you can easily limit your graph and re
kind of reshape the way it looks quite
easily and we can also add that grid
down there if we want a grid
we'll run that and add the grid in there
oops i guess you have to do the grid
beforehand
switch that there we go sometimes the
order on this is really important so you
may double check your order when you're
printing these things out it also helps
if i change it to one so in this case
might not be the order i wonder if we'll
go back here as one there we go so
doesn't matter the order and grid but
you can set the grid for easy viewing
here nice setup on there but you can see
how we can limit the data
so let's start looking at some other 2d
graphs and make this cell a markdown so
we run it as a nice pretty title to it
and let's go ahead and create some data
with an np array we'll do
0 to 5 on here there we go and let's
look at uh four common graphs we'll put
them side by side so we'll do a figure
our axes equals plot subplots one four
columns and then figure size hopefully
it'll fit nicely on here it seems to do
a pretty good on here and i'll go and
just run that since we're in there run
you'll see i have my four blank plots on
here
and we'll start with axes of zero let's
set title
and we want this to be a scatter plot
a scatter plot just means it has a bunch
of dots on it so here's our axes of
zero
dot scatter easy to remember scatter a
bunch of plots on there we'll do our
n we can do x or n there we go and let's
go ahead and do axes set title scatter
i've already did that we're just going
to do scatter
that's how you do it on there notice how
you create a scatter plot with simply
with the scatter control and we'll do
let's do the variable x
x
plus let's throw some randomness in here
usually scatter plots are i have a lot
of random numbers connected to them
that's why they do them on there and so
the bigger the x gets the bigger the
randomness so 0.25 times the randomness
and what we should end up doing here is
with the scatter plot and you can see as
you go up it just kind of has some
random numbers and moves up and down the
line but plus just the points so if you
remember from back up here where we did
marker
this is plotting basically just the
marker so it's a scatter plot
probably less used is a step plot so for
exes one we'll go ahead and do a step
plot so you can see what that looks like
and this time i'll use our n value
instead of x we generated that n value
up here and so for this we have n n
times two r n squared n times two n
squared line width equals two and if we
run that it creates a nice step
up let's see so we've got a scatter plot
we've got a step
plot let's do a bar plot
and we'll use the same formula in n
squared alignment centered because you
can have them left or right with 0.5 and
alpha if you remember correctly that's
how opaque it is
let's see what that looks like on there
so we have some nice you can see here a
nice bar plot it should look very
similar to the step plot but colored in
and we can change the width let's see
what happens we do 0.9 run
and if we take width out completely
run that you can see it starts coming
together on there and we can change the
alpha we can take the alpha out too and
run that so now you have the solid
colors and if we take out the center
and run that
everything you really can't see the
shift on here because that's actually
the default on this but these are common
settings for the bar graph let me just
put them back in there there we go
alignment center and alpha
now i can't say i've used the step craft
very much there's certain other certain
i guess domains of expertise require a
step graph but the scatter plot and the
bar graph very common especially the bar
graph and we'll look at histograms here
in just a minute so i use histograms a
lot especially in data science but this
is nice if you have very uh concrete
objects somebody how many people wearing
yellow hats that kind of thing but if
we're going to do that let's go ahead
and do the last one which i see a lot
more in the sciences certainly using the
data science but more like for mapping i
saw publication on
solar flares and they were discussing
the energy and so filling in the graph
gives it a very different look so we're
going to do the fill between
and it's just like you think it'd be
it's fill between but with a underscore
between them and we'll do x and x
squared and x and x cubed and we'll do
color green and alpha again in case you
had other data you want to plot on there
you can see it forms a nice squared
coming up here and also if you look at
the bottom one is your squared value the
upper line is your cubed value and then
it fills in everything in between
if you remember from calculus
this would be if you had like a car a
motor and efficiency they would talk
about the efficiency going up and the
loss and you're looking for the space or
the area between the two lines so it
gives you a nice visual of that now
let's look at a few more basic two
dimensionals so we have our figure
figure size on here we're going to do a
radar chart to be honest i've never used
a radar chart in business or in data
science i can't find a reason to use one
now so the first line for doing a radar
chart we have to add axes into the
figure and with this this actually
creates our
oh let's let's run it so you can see
what it creates it creates a nice looks
like you're on a submarine and you're
tracking the hunt for red october or
something like that and it needs all of
these the polar is the fact that we're
doing polar coordinates
zero zero point six point six has to do
with the size if you take out any of
these things and run them you get just a
box if you take out the other half you
pretty much get nothing in there and if
you change these numbers and change them
a little bit you can see it gets bigger
they had 0.6 on here i'll go ahead and
leave it as one because that's just kind
of fun that's all about the size on here
the height and the width and then let's
create some data t equals np line space
and this is 0 to 2 times np times pi so
if you remember that is the
distance across and we're going to
generate a hundred points
so this is just a thing of data we're
putting together then we simply do an ax
dot plot and in this case let's do t
comma t which would be a diagonal line
on a regular chart and we'll give it a
nice color equals blue
and line width equals three let's see
what that looks like and we can see here
a spiral coming out remember this would
be just a diagonal line on a regular
chart what happens if we take this and
instead of t
times 0.5 there we go
and you can see it slightly alters the
way it spirals out we could do t times
two spirals that a little quicker so
it's kind of just a fun i've like i said
i've never used a
radar chart it's a column but you can
always think of radar submarine kind of
looks like one of those or in an
airplane
and none of this would be complete if we
didn't discuss histograms oh my gosh do
i use a histogram so much and we'll use
our numpy that we have set as np to
generate oh looks like we have a hundred
thousand variables we're going to set
equal to n and of course we create our
figure and our axes subplots 1 2 figure
size 12 14. so we're going to look at
two different variations of the
histogram and we'll set a title default
histogram set our title there
and then this is simply
hist for histogram and we'll just go
ahead and put in our n in there and let
me run this and see what that looks like
and let's talk about what is going on
here
so we generated an array here of data
one thousand random arrays
looks like they're mostly between minus
four and four
and then it adds up each one it says
zero you have 35 000 that are zero so
that's what's most common on here and we
have 20 000 that are somewhere in this
range right here between the minus two
and well it looks like one minus two and
somewhere between 0 and 1 there's 30 000
numbers so all this is saying is this is
how common these variables are and this
gives you this point in so many
directions when you're looking at data
science to go ahead and run your
histogram so you should always have your
histogram and you can always put limits
and all the other different things on
your array just like you did on the
other graphs on there and then we're
going to do a cumulative detailed
histogram and all it is is a histogram
let me just do that
and we set cumulative equal to true
and bins equal 50. and i really want to
highlight the
cumulative equals true is important but
we can now choose how many bins we have
in the first one it kind of selected
them for us in this case let me go ahead
and run this and you'll see it has the
prints of data out for us and here's our
whoops
must have missed oh there we go doesn't
help that i put it over the old one
there we go okay
so now you have your default histogram
and then we have a cumulative histogram
and we should have 50 steps in there and
let's just find out if that's true not
so much by counting them i'm not going
to count them if you want to you can
count them let's just change it to 10
and see what happens and we see here we
have now 10 counts of that
and we could set that for 5
and run that
and then we have our 5 on there and we
go ahead and take the cumulative equals
true out just so you can see what that
looks like and let me run that on here
too
that looks just like it did before i
think there's what one two three four
five six seven eight they have eight
different bins on here is what the
default came out of
put that back in there run
and so now it should look almost
identical and it does and then we can
put the cumulative back in see what that
looks like with the cumulative
and run that
and we can see how that shifts
everything over and has a slightly
different luck
wait it shifts it all to the right no it
doesn't actually shift it to the right
it's cumulative so it's the total of the
different occurrences and so what that
means is like if you consider this like
for the year of rainfall we have like
day one you had a little bit of rain day
two we have more rain and so if you look
at the number this is a hundred thousand
thirty five thousand so it's a
cumulative detail the histogram of the
currents as it grows and rainfall is a
good one because that would be a
cumulative histogram of how much rain
occurred throughout the year and we're
going to look at two more graphs we've
already looked at a bunch of them we
looked at our radar graph we've looked
at scatter step bar fill in
basic plots we've looked at different
ways of showing the data you know we can
increase the size of the line the look
the color the alpha setting
so let's look at contour maps let's put
that in there there we go draw a contour
map and before we draw a contour map
we need to go ahead and create data for
it and if you have contours your data is
all going to have three different values
so let's go ahead and create the data
here we have our you'd import your
matplot library your numpy so we have
our numbers array
we'll import mapplot.com
and that's your color maps so you have
all these different color maps you can
look at there's like hundreds of color
maps so if you don't want to do your own
color you can even do your own color map
they're pretty
diverse and of course our plt we're
going to our pi plot and to generate our
different data we're going to create a
delta
0.025 and we'll start with x when we're
going to create an array between -3 and
3 and delta increments of
0.025 we'll have our y we'll do
something similar and then we'll create
our x y into a mesh grid again these are
all numpy commands so if you're not
familiar with these you'll want to go
back and review our numpy tutorial and
we'll do an exponential on here minus x
squared minus y squared for z1 we'll do
a z2 so we have two different areas and
z equals z of 1 minus z2 times 2.
so we've created a number of values here
and let me go ahead and run this and
let's plug that in so you can see where
those values are going so once we've set
these we're going to create our figure
and our x from our plt subplots we're
going to create the variable cs and this
is going to be our contour so right here
cs is our contour surface and we're
feeding it x y and z if you remember x y
we created as our x and y components
using our mesh grid and you know what
let's do this just because it's kind of
good to see this let's go ahead and
print
x
and let's print
y and i always like to do this when i'm
working with something that's either is
really complicated in this case is what
we're looking at or you don't understand
yet so we've created a mesh grid we have
x y and when we're done with this we end
up with here's our x
and this set of values and our y so
those are x and y coordinates and then
we've also created z based on our x and
y so we have x capital x capital y and
capital z is our three components x and
y be in the coordinates while z is going
to be our actual height since we're
doing a contour map so we created our
contour map from our x y and z
coordinates we want to go ahead and put
in a c label maybe we want to go ahead
and do a title on here
we'll put that in our set title and this
is a
contour there we go contour map and
let's go ahead and run this and see what
that looks like
and you'll see we generated a nice
little contour map there's different
settings you can play with on this but
you can picture this being you're on a
mountain climb and here we have a line
that's represent zero maybe at sea level
and then moving on up you have your
contours of 0.5 and then -1 and
different setups little hills i guess if
it's minus that's like a pit so i guess
you're going down into a pit at -5 and
-1 when on the other side you can see
you're going up in levels so here's a
mountaintop and here's like a basin of
some kind and in data science this could
represent a lot of things this could
also be representing two different
values and maybe profits and loss i
don't know if i'd ever really do that as
a contour map but i'm sure you can be
creative and find something fun to do
with a contour map and then we're going
to look at one last map which is the 3d
map and those are can be really
important as a final product because
they can show so much additional
information that you can't fit on
two-dimensional graphs
there we go draw a 3d image and so we're
going to import from our
mpl toolkits the implant 3d and the axis
3d we're going to import axis 3d this is
what's going to let us work with the 3d
image and this should look familiar
we're going to create another figure
just like we did before figure size 14x6
that's a good fit on the screen we'll go
ahead and run that
so we have our figure and let's go ahead
and take our x and we're going to set
that equal to fig dot add subplot that
should also be familiar from earlier and
we're going to work with this sets the
settings for the projection we're going
to use one two one projection 3d and
we'll see what that looks like in just a
minute and we just created some
three-dimensional data here before
where we had x y and z capital x y and z
so we're going to reuse that data we're
just going to use that since this also
this is also a three-dimensional image
so let's use that for a
three-dimensional graph and we simply do
ax plot underscore
surface
and our capital x
capital y capital z so there's our data
coming in and we're going to add some
settings in here we're going to do r
stride 4 c stride 4 and line width 0.
i'll show you what that is here in just
a minute let's go ahead and run that so
we can see our graph
and of course it helps if i don't add an
extra comma in there and you can see it
generates this really beautiful
three-dimensional graph
so let's take a little bit time to
explore some of these numbers we have
going in here
we have the r stride 4 the c stride 4
and the projection 3d projection 3d is
the important one because that's telling
us that this is a 3d graph here
so what are these first numbers 1 2 1
let's just change one of these i'm going
to change this to 5
and it's going to give me an error let's
change it to 1.
and that didn't work let's change this
middle one to three instead
and you're going to see how it starts
reshaping the size and how it fits on
the screen
and we'll change the first one to two
we'll run that one
and again it's changed the dimensions
and the size and how it fits on here
play with these numbers to get a nice
look and feel for it part of it is the
tilt and the angle
i'll do seven on this one
there we go you can see it really
shifted it there but again that changes
the size now it fits on the canvas
but we'll leave it at the one
two and just so you get a good look at
what we're talking about here this is
column width and index from before
if we do 1 1 1 you can see that it now
spreads it out all the way across uses
the whole set up on there so this has to
do with the size and how big you want it
to be now there's one term that we
didn't cover in this yet but we've used
it throughout the whole setup
and i'm just going to type that down
here even though we're not going to go
into detail and that's the term heat
map you might see that it's kind of
starting to lose ground as far as a
common reference but there sure are a
lot of people who still talk about heat
maps what is a heat map well it is
simply a color map that's all it is so
if you ever see the term heat map
that refers to the fact this is in
different colors representing different
heights
that one is in the heat map but you can
see up here we switched into
let me go back up here here we go this
one has different colors for the
different values
a lot of times you'll use like instead
of x and y you might do a heat map
where you have a fourth value and the
fourth value represents the color and so
you'll see this 3d image in the nice
colors represented by heat map that's
all it is so if you see the term heat
map that only means we're plotting some
of the data in color to make it stand
out or to give it a fourth dimension in
this case
so we've covered a lot of things on
matplot and that brings us cover all the
basics so that brings us to practice
example and this is going to be the
challenge for you and let me go ahead
and change our cell
cell type mark down and run that so it
looks pretty
practice example write a path python
program to create a pie chart of the
popularity of programming languages
okay excellent
and if you're going to have a challenge
we need some data and i'll just throw in
our import our map library at the
beginning you should do that
automatically and so for our data to
plot we're going to have our languages
we're going to have python we're going
to have java php javascript c-sharp
c-plus plus so those are six categories
and then we have our popularity oops
misspelling there popularity we'll give
the first one 22.2 percent java 17.6 and
i don't know if these are real numbers
they pulled
my guess is that they might have just
been made up because i don't know if
python's really that much more popular
than the other ones maybe specific to
data science because python is very
popular in data science right now
because it has so many options the only
other program that's highly used and
exclusively for data science is r so
python's big and python also does a lot
more it's a full programming language
where r is primarily for data science
they didn't put r in here so we have
python we have java we have our php and
you can see the different values they've
given it or different percentages
and i did add these up does not add up
to 100 it adds up to 71 percent or
something like that
and then we're going to give colors and
we've chosen these guys in the back
brought in these colors i'm not sure
what these colors are we'll find out in
a minute so i'll be exciting but you can
see they're using the actual color
values you can pull off of a color wheel
or something like that you could have
just as easily done blue red green if
you're too lazy to pick the exact colors
and then let's go ahead and solve this
and see we got here we're going to do
something a little fancy just because we
can
the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to use a variable called
explode and you'll notice that there's
six variables in here so that matches
our six different categories and the
first one we've done is point one and
then zero zero zero zero zero point one
when we put this in here under the
explode in the plot it will actually
push that square out so it's a really
cool feature to highlight certain
information on a pie chart
and this is simply
plt dot pi and we're plotting
popularity there we go
and before we add in all the really cool
settings for this let's go ahead and run
it and you'll see we generate a nice
flat pie not too exciting there and then
we'll go ahead and put in all the extras
i talked about explode where we can
explode one of the values out so here's
our explode equals explode labels as
languages because we want to know what
the different colors mean here's our
colors equals colors our auto picture
and this is standard print format so
that's a python setup on there and
that's just going to put the value on
the pie slice and then we're going to
add shadow because it just looks cooler
with a shadow gives a little 3d look and
we'll do a start angle of 140. let's go
ahead and run this and take a look and
see what comes out of that
and look how that changes the whole
setup so here's our labels there's our
value we put on there there's our slice
that's pushed out there's our shadow a
3d effect
and then we started at 140 we could also
rotate this let's just do this angle
and if we run it
you'll see the blue pi slice has moved
up a little bit we could actually do
actually let's just take the whole
starting triangle out and run it'll
default to zero
this is what it looks like if it
defaulted to zero so depending on where
you want the highlighted slice to appear
usually you want that appear on the left
because people read left to right and so
it draws a focus onto in this case
python and how great python is i'm a
little biased we're teaching a python
tutorial so it should be understandable
that we're looking at python and one
last reference before we close you can
go over to the matplot library dot pi
plot set up and if you go underneath
there the different functions on there
you can look this up on their website
you'll see a full list and this is why
it's so important to go through a
tutorial like this because this list is
just so massive trying to figure out
like here's our bar plot there's a bar h
you can add barbs there's a box plot we
didn't cover
c labels a totally different kind of for
your contour plot you can set up in
there if you go down here we have our
figures we used on there we showed you
the basics how to do the figure you'll
see some
closer references on those
there's a histogram down here hist
there's also the his 2d makes a 2d
histogram plot h lines all of this these
are all the different commands that are
underneath of here and you can see it's
pretty extensive we've covered all the
basic ones so that you know have a solid
ground to look at these different
options so when you come to these
functions some of them are going to look
a little off or not off will look
unfamiliar but you'll still have the
availability to probably understand most
of this and have a basic understanding
of your matplot library what is pandas
pandas is a tool for data processing
which helps in data analysis it provides
functions and methods to efficiently
manipulate large data sets now this is a
step down from say using spark or hadoop
in big data so we're not talking about
big data here but we are talking about
pandas when there is some connections
there's like an interface going on with
that so there is availability but you
really should know your pandas because
if you're working in big data you'll
know there's data frames well pandas is
a data frame primarily it has a couple
different pieces we'll look at here and
if you've never worked with data frames
before a data frame is basically like an
excel spreadsheet you have rows and
columns you can access your data either
by the row or the column and you have an
index in different that kind of setup
and we'll dig more into that as we get
deeper into pandas but think of it as
like a giant excel spreadsheet that's
optimized to run on larger data on your
computer
and then i said it that it's a data
frame so the data structures in pandas
are series one dimensional arrays
and then we have data frame
two-dimensional array and it really
centers around the data frame the series
just happens to be part of that data
frame and here's a closer look at a
panda series series is a one-dimensional
array with labels it can contain any
data type including integers strings
floats python objects and more so it's
very diverse if you remember from numpy
we studied they had to be all uniform
not in pandas and pandas we can do a lot
more and pen is actually kind of sits on
numpy so you really need to know both of
those if you haven't done the numpy
tutorials and you can see here we have
our index one two three four five and
then our data a b c d and e very
straightforward it's just two columns
and we have a nice index label and a
column label for the data and then a
data frame is a two dimensional data
structure with labels we can use labels
to locate data and you can see here we
had if we go back one we had our index
one two three four five so in each one
of these series they would share the
same index over there the row index so
you have your row index df dot index and
then you have a column index df.columns
and this should look like i said this
would be really familiar if you've done
any work with spreadsheets excel so it
kind of resembles that this does make it
a lot easier to manipulate data and add
columns delete columns move them around
same thing with the rows so you have a
lot of control over all of this now
we're of course going to do this in our
jupiter notebook you can use any of your
python editors but i highly suggest if
you haven't installed jupiter and
haven't worked with it it is probably
one of the best ways for easily
displaying a project you're working on i
skip between a lot of different user
interfaces or ides for editing my python
and it's just simply jupiter.org
j-u-p-y-t-e-r.org
and then i always let mine sit on
anaconda
anaconda.com
and just real quick we'll open that up
for you oops offline mode don't show me
that again
but you can see here that i have
different tools that i can actually
install in my anaconda including the
jupiter notebook which comes by default
and then i have access to the
environments
and again that's
anaconda.com named after the very large
one of the largest world's largest
snakes and then jupiter notebook in this
case jupiter.org and when we're in our
i'm going to go in here to our jupiter
notebook and we're going to go ahead and
just do new and a python 3
and this will open up a python 3
untitled folder
so diving right in let's go ahead and
give this a title panda's tutorial and
we'll go up to cell and we'll change the
cell type to mark down so it doesn't
execute it as actual code one of those
wonderful tools when you have jupyter
notebook so you can do demos with this
and let's go ahead and import
pandas
and usually people just call it pd that
has become such a standard in the
industry so we'll go ahead and run that
now we have our pandas has been imported
into our jupiter notebook
and then we can go ahead and let me do
the control plus since it's internet
explorer i can enlarge it very easily so
you have a nice pretty view whoops too
big
there we go and whenever you're working
with a new module it's good to check
your version of the module in pandas you
just use the in this case pd dot
underscore underscore version underscore
underscore that's actually pretty common
in most of our python modules there's
different ways to look up the version
but that's one of the more common ones
and we'll go ahead and run that we get
.23.4
and if we go to the pandas site we see
0.23.4 as the latest release
and of course a reminder that if you're
going to environment you need to install
it so you'll need to pip install pandas
if you're using the pip installer we'll
close out of that and the first thing we
want to do is we're going to work with
series a lot of stuff you do in series
you can then do on the whole data set we
need to do what create one we need to
manipulate it
take pieces of it so query it query it
delete so you can delete different parts
of it so we want to do all those things
with the series and we'll start with the
series and then almost all the code in
fact all the code does transfer
right into
the actual data table so we go from a
series of a single list of one column
and then we'll take that and we'll
transfer that over to the whole table
and we'll start by creating let's put up
there we go
creating a series from
list
and let's just call this arr equals
and we'll do
0 1 2 3 4. if you remember from our last
one we could easily do
r equals
range of five which would be zero to
four but we'll do r equals zero to four
and we'll call this s1 and we'll go pd
and
series is capitalized this one always
throws me is which letters do you
capitalize on these modules they're
getting more and more uniform but you
got to watch that with python and we're
just going to go ahead and do arr
so we're just going to take this python
list and we're going to turn it into a
series
and then because we're in jupiter we
don't have to put the print statement we
can just put s1 and it'll print out this
series for us
and let's go ahead and run that and take
a look
and you'll see we have two rows of
numbers so the first one is the index
now it automatically creates the index
starting with 0 unless you tell it to do
differently so we get 0 index row 0 is 0
1 1 2 2 3 3 4 4. and because it's a
series it doesn't need a title for the
column there's only one column so why
title it
and this also lets you know that it's a
data type of integer 64. so we print
this out this is our series our basic
series we've just created
now let's do a second series
pd and we'll use the same
data list and let's go ahead and do
order we'll give it an order
equals oh let's do it this way let's go
index
equals order
and it helps if we actually give it an
order so we'll do order
equals and let's do one two three four
five so instead of starting with zero
we're going to give it an order starting
with one we're going to run that
and we'll go ahead and print it out down
here s2
and we'll see that we now have an index
of 1 2 3 4 5 and that represents 0 1 2 3
4 in the series and we're still data
type integer 64.
and very common as you're missing with
numpy arrays is we can import our numpy
as np remember that from our numpy
tutorials we can go ahead and create a
numpy out of random with the random
numbers of five
and let's just see what that end looks
like so we see what our number looks
like so we have some nice random float
values here 2.33 so on and this from our
last tutorial the numpy tutorial 1 and
2. and instead of calling it order let's
call it index and we're going to set our
index equal to a b c d and e
i want to show you that the index
doesn't have to be an integer so it can
be something very different here and
then let's go ahead and create our we'll
just use s2 again and here's our np for
numpy
series capital s
and n is our
np for numpy
pd for pandas there we go switching my
anachronisms so we have pd.series of n
and we're going to do our index
equals our index we just created
and then let's go ahead and see what
that looks like s2 is a print it and
let's run that
and we can see here we have a nice
series going on a b c d and e for our
indexes so instead of being 0 1 2 3 or 4
we can make this index whatever we want
and you can see the numbers here going
down that we randomly generated from the
number array so we use numpy to create
our panda series right here and so
continuing on with creating our series
this one i use so often we create a
series from a dictionary so we have our
dictionary in this case we went ahead
and did a of one b is two c a three d
four e of five so each one of those is a
key and then a value and then we're
going to use oh let's use s3 equals pd
for pandas
series
and then we want to go ahead and just do
d in here
print out s3 here and let's go ahead and
run this and you can see we got a is one
b is two c is three d is four e is five
and it's still of integer 64 because the
actual data is one two three four five
and it's all integer 64 type 64. and the
last thing we want to do in the creating
section of our series is to go ahead and
modify the index because we're going to
start modifying all this data so let's
start with modifying the index of the
series and if you remember let's do a
print this time s1
i'll go ahead and run this and the
reason i did print is because it only
prints out the last variable so if i put
s1 up here and we're going to do another
variable back down lower it won't print
the first one just the last one and
we're going to go ahead and take s1
the index and we're just going to set it
equal to a new index and obviously the
number of objects in our index has to
equal the number of objects in our data
and then because it's the last variable
we can go ahead and just do an s1 and
let's run that and you can see how we
went from 0 to 0 0 1 2 3 4 as our index
we've now altered it to a b c d and e
so this would be much more readable or
might be representational of a larger
database you're working with
so cool tools we've covered creating a
database based on
our basic array python array we've
showed you how to
reset the index
then we showed you how to use a numpy
array so you can put a numpy array in
there it's all the same you know
pd.series a numpy array and then we can
set the index on there and the same
thing with the dictionary so it's very
versatile how it pulls in data and you
can pull in data from different sources
and different setups and create a new
series very easily in the pandas and
then we left on changing your index so
now we have a new index on here and then
we want to go ahead and do some
selection let's do some basic
slicing most common thing you'll
probably do on here and we'll just do s1
this notation should start to look
really familiar again this is going to
put an output so i'd usually it doesn't
change s1 this just selects it so we
might do a equals s1 and then print a
and you'll see that it just looks at the
first three zero one two and we can do
the same thing by not having the a in
there i'll go ahead and take that out
but just a reminder that it's not
actually changing s1 it's just viewing
s1 so simple slicing on here and we can
likewise do an append oops before we do
a pen let's just do a quick kind of fun
one we'll do two minus one and you'll
see it covers everything but the e of
course you can do minus two on this side
so one another way to select it is to go
how far from the end and likewise we can
do a two here a cde to the end so it
starts at the second one and another way
we can do this is we can do a minus 2
over here
and that looks at just the last two in
the slice so you can see how easy it is
to slice the data and of course
there's no reason to do this but you
could select all of them
if you wanted to view all of them on
there helps 32 there's not 32 so it's
just going to show the first three there
we go and then we can also append so i
can take and oh let's create another
series and append one to it and if you
remember we had s3 there's our s3 and we
have our s1 we'll go ahead and do s1
and let's go ahead and do
oh let's call it s4
equals s1
a pin
s3
so we're just going to combine those two
into s4
and if we go ahead and print s4 on here
you'll now see that we have a b c d e a
b c d e zero one two three four one two
three four five because we started the
data at one
it's a very easy to append one series to
the next
and if we're going to append one series
to the next we need to go ahead and drop
or delete one and drop is a key word for
that and let's just do e or index e and
so if i run this
you'll see that it'll print it out and
a b c d there's no e and remember all
these changes if i type in s4 again
you'll see that s4 still has e in it so
this change does not affect the series
unless you tell it to so i'd have to do
like x s4 equals s4.drop e and there's
another way to do that which we'll show
you later on let me just cut this one
out
there we go
all right so we've covered all kinds of
cool tools here we have appending we
have slicing we did all the creating
stuff earlier as you can see here on the
setup how easy it is to manipulate the
series
so next what we want to get into is we
want to get into
operations that happen on the series let
me go ahead and change this cell to
markdown there we go and run that
so series operations what can we do with
the series and let's start by creating a
couple arrays we'll call it array 1 and
we'll do 0 through 7 and array 2 6
through six seven eight nine five i
don't know if we threw the five on the
end let's go ahead and run those so
those load up into jupiter
and we'll do this a little backwards
we're going to do s5 equals a panda
series of array two so i'm doing this in
reverse and then when we do s5 you'll
see that we have zero to four it
automatically assign the index
for our series
and let's go ahead and do the same and
we'll call this s6 and we'll set this
equal to pd series for
our first array
and if we do an s6 down here to print it
out
we'll see something similar i got zero
through six
zero one two three four five seven for
the data so those are two series we just
created series six five and six
and one of the first things we can do is
we can add one series to the next so i
can do s5 dot add s6 and let's see what
that generates and just a quick thing if
you never use pandas what do you think
is going to happen with the fact that
this only has five different values in
it and this one has seven values
so let's see what that does
and we end up with 6 8 10 12 9 and it
goes oh i can't add this there's nothing
there so it gives us a null return very
different than the numpy that would have
given you an error this instead tells
you there's no value here because we
couldn't generate one so we can easily
add s5 dot add s6 and likewise we can do
s5 dot
sub for subtract s6
and we'll run that and on the add the
subtract and you guessed it we're going
to do multiply and divide next again you
can see there's the null values where it
can't subtract the two because there's
no values there to subtract we can also
do s5 multiply mul they're all three
letters on these that's one of the ways
to remember how they figured out the
code for this so remember these are all
three letters mole we'll go ahead and
run this
and you can you can see how they're
multiplied together and then we can also
do the s5 div three letters again
s6
and run that
and you'll see here this goes to
infinity because we have zero in the
wrong position so it actually gives you
a whole different answer here that's
important to notice and then in the null
values because there's no data and it
can't actually produce an answer off of
an old off of missing data and since
we're in data science let's do s6
median so let's look at the median data
which is simply uh median sorry for
those who are following the three
letters because median is not three
letters and you can see an s6 is 3.0 and
let's do a print here and we'll do
median
or average
s6
and let's print max
comma s6
and just like median there's max value
and if we're going to have a max value
we should also have a minimum value so
let's pop in minimum
we'll go ahead and run this and you're
starting to see something that would be
generated like say an r where you're
starting to get your different
statistics we have a medium value of 3
max value of 7 and a minimum value of 0.
and what it does when it hits these null
values
if there is no values in there because
we could still do that we could actually
you know what let's go up here and do
let's pick this one where we multiplied
let's go s7
equals
i'll go and print the s7 just so i keep
it nice and uniform so i still have my
s7 down there and run it
and then i want to take the s7
because s7 now has
null values and an infinity value and
let's see what happens this is gonna be
interesting cause i wanna see what it is
with infinity
and we end up with a median of six
maximum of 27 and minimum of zero which
is correct it drops those values so when
it gets to there and it doesn't know
what to do with them it just drops those
values and then it computes it on the
remaining data on there so it's
important to know when you're making
these computations you're looking at min
and max and median
you're not going to know that there's no
values unless you double check your data
for the null values it's a very
important thing to note on there so just
a real quick
review on there we've done our created
our pd series and we've gone ahead and
done addition subtraction multiplication
division all those are three letters so
sub min div add
and then we looked at median maximum and
minimum so we're going to go ahead and
jump into the next big topic which is to
create a data frame
so now we're going to go from series and
we're going to create a number of series
and bundle them together to make a data
frame
there we go cell type markdown let me go
ahead and run that so we have a nice
title on there it's always good to have
a good title all right so our first data
frame we'll jump in with some stuff that
looks a little complicated we'll break
it down first i'm going to create some
dates and you know what let's just go
ahead and do this i want you to see what
that looks like what i'm creating here
i've created a series of dates pd date
range and we're going to use these for
the index okay so when you look at this
you'll see that it's just basically it
comes out kind of like a basic python
list or a numpy array however you want
to look at it with our different dates
going down and we've generated six of
them and it's going to have whatever
time it is right now on your on the
thing for the date for the time that's
that time stamp right there and then
you'll see we have 11 19 2008 11 20 11
19 and looking into the future there so
that's all this is is generating a
series of dates that we're going to use
as our index and this is a pandas
command so we have a date range which is
nice it's one of the tools hidden in
there in the pandas that you can use
and next we're going to use numpy to go
ahead and generate some random numbers
in this case we'll do the
np.random.random in 6 comma 4. you can
look at this as rows and columns as we
move it into the pandas and of course
you could reshape this if you had those
backwards on your data but we want the
six to match the rows and we have six
periods so our indexes should match
along with the rows on there and then
you know before we do the next one let's
go ahead and just print out our numpy
arrays and see what that looks like here
we have it one two three four by one two
three four five six four by six
so it's a nice little setup on there and
since working with data frames can be
very visual let's give our columns we
have four columns and we're going to
give them names a b c and d
so now we have columns on there also and
then let's put this all together in a
data frame and we can actually you know
what let's do this since i did it with
everything else let's go ahead and do
columns and you can see there's our
columns on there
and we'll go ahead and do df1
equals
pandas dot
data frame and note that the d and the f
are capitalized series it was just the s
and i always highlight this because you
don't know how many times these things
get retyped when you forget what's
capitalized on there it's a minor thing
you'll pick it up right away if you do a
lot of it and the first thing we want to
do is we want to go ahead and take our
numpy array because that's what we're
going to create our data frame off of
it's a numpy array and then we want our
index equal to our dates so there's our
index in there and then we also have
columns equals
columns
and then finally let's see what that
looks like now remember we had all the
different data that just looked like a
jumble of data we have our column names
and everything else our numpy array kind
of just a jumble array over there four
by six you could sort of read it but
look how nice this looks i mean this is
you come into a board meeting you're
working with your
shareholders
this is pretty readable this is you know
this is our date this is our a b c d
whatever it is maybe each one of these
dates has your leads
closures lost leads
total dollar made you know whatever it
is if it's in a business maybe it's
measurements on some scientific
equipment whether searching material you
know where this is like
higher the temperature low of the day
humidity of the day whatever it is so
you can see that we can really create a
nice clear chart and it looks just like
a spreadsheet you know we have our rows
and we have our columns and we have our
data in there now this one i use all the
time if we're going to create we can
create it like you saw here with our
numpy array very easy to do that and
reshape it you can also create it with a
dictionary array so here we have some
data let me just go down a notch so you
can see all the data on there we have an
animal in this case cat cat snake dog
dog cat snake cat dog we have the age so
we have an array of ages we have the
number of visits and the priority was it
a high priority yes
no
and then we're going to take that we're
going to create some labels we have a b
c d e f g h i and what i want you to
notice on this is we have a title animal
and then we have basically a python list
and these lists they don't necessarily
have to be equal because we can have
non-data you know
numpy array null value but we want to go
ahead and create labels that are equal
to the number in the list so a
the first cat b the second cat c the
snake d the dog and so on so we'll go
ahead and create our labels which we're
going to use as an index and we'll call
this df let's do it this way we'll call
this df2
equals pd for pandas
data frame
and then we have our data just like we
did before and then we have our index
equals
labels
and if we're going to go from there
let's go ahead and print it out so we
can see what that looks like df2 so
let's go ahead and run that another
again you have a nice very clean chart
to look at we've gone from this mess of
data here to what looks like a very
organized spreadsheet very visual and
easy to read
animal age visits priority and then a
through j cats and all your different
animals so on and so on and then when
you do programming a lot of times it's
important to know what the data types
are so we can simply do df2
d types
and if we run that we can see that our
animal
is an object because it's just a string
but it comes in as an object age is a
float 64 integer 64 and then priority
again is just an object
and exploring this this one's very
popular let's go df2
[Music]
head
and if we print that out the df2 head
returns the first five and we can change
this you don't have to do five you might
want to just look at the top two maybe
you want to look at
let's see oh let's do six so maybe we'll
look at just the top six in the database
in your data frame and you can actually
this creates another data frame so i
could have a df3 equal to df2 and this
now takes the df2 and just the first six
values
so if we do df3
run get the same answer
and if we do it the head of the data we
can also do the tail it's the same thing
df tail you can look at the last
we'll just do the tell which by default
does five the last five and of course
you can just look at the last three of
those real quick just to see what's at
the end of the data and this is i need
to tell i love doing the tail of one
because i'll have like the index or
something like that and it will just
show me the last whatever the last entry
was looking at stock values and i might
want to look at just the last five days
of the stock values i can do that with
the data frame tail
and some other key things to look up are
the index so we can do df2.index
and i want you to notice that this isn't
a call function so if i put the brackets
on the end it'll give me an error
because index is not callable it's just
an object in there
so we do df2.index
there's also columns
so we can go ahead and let's do uh let's
print this
remember the first one is not going to
show unless i
print it and then df2 columns so now we
can see that we have our indexes
and we have our columns listed here
df2.columns animal age visits priority
it tells you what kind of object it is
or what kind of data type it is and
they're both object
and then finally df2 dot
values and again there's no brackets on
the end of df2.values
because this is an actual object it's
not a callable function so we'll go
ahead and run that
and it creates just displays a nice
array a very easy way to convert this
back to a numpy array basically so
before i go into the next section let's
just take a quick look at what we
covered so far with the data frame we
came up here we created our data frame
we did it from a numpy array first
setting the columns and the index the
index is setting it up is the same as
when we set up the series so that should
look very familiar so is the whole
format the numpy array the index dates
and the columns columns and remember in
our numpy array we're looking at row
comma column so six rows four columns is
how that reads in the data frame
and we went ahead and also did that from
a dictionary in this case animal was the
column name with all the date data
underneath that column and then age with
that data visits that data priority that
data and then of course we added our
labels in there for our index so there's
no difference in there but it
automatically pulled the column names
important to know when you're dealing
with a data frame and importing a data
frame this way
and then we did looking up d type we
looked at head and tail looking at your
data really quick
we also did index and columns and values
and note these don't have the brackets
on the end
so the next thing we want to do is go
ahead since we're dealing with data
science is we want to go and describe
the data so we have
df2.described to do that and we're going
to manipulate it in just a minute but
let's just see what this generates
and you can see right here we have age
and visits
so looking at our data from up above let
me just go all the way up here
animal age visits priority
and it does a nice job generating your
age versus visits which has all the data
you have your account your means your
standard deviation your minimum value
25 percent or in this group 50 75 and
your maximum value so this should look
familiar as a data science setup with
your describe for a quick look at your
data frame data so let's start
manipulating this data frame moving
stuff around and we'll start with
transposing and it is simply capital t
for transpose
and when we run that it flips the
columns and the indexes so now the
indexes are all column names and the
columns are all indexes animal age
visits priority
so if we had come in here with our data
shaped wrong up above where we had a 4x6
we can quickly just swap it if we had it
backwards not a big deal and we can also
sort our data something that you can't
do which is more difficult to do with a
lot of other packages in the data frame
it's really easy to do take our data
frame df2 and we're going to sort
underscore values
by equals age and so when we run this
you'll see the default is ascending so
we have 0.52 2.53 and everything else is
organized so if you look at your indexes
they've been moved around because each
index it moves a whole row not just the
one piece of data is not being sorted
so very quick way to sort by age are
different data in the data frame and in
addition to sorting it we can also slice
the data frame so i could do df2 and
this should look familiar from earlier
we'll just do one
to three so we're going to pull out oops
it does help if i use a df instead of
just d and we're going to pull up just
between one and three so we have not
zero which is a but we have b which is
two or b which is one and c which is 2.
so 1 2 and then it does not include 3
which is the standard in python and we
can even do something like this we can
combine them which is always fun because
remember this returns a data frame so if
i take df2
dot
sort
values and we'll do by
equals age this is just kind of fun and
then i'm going to slice it
there we go double check my typing and
run it
and now you should see fa because fa are
now one and two on there
so you can very quickly create a whole
string on here which narrows it you know
that you can sort it then slice it and
do all kinds of fun things with your
data frame we'll just go back to the
original one run there we go and if we
can slice it by row we can also query
the data frame so we can do df2 and this
is a little different because i'm going
to create an array within an array and
in this case we're going to look at oh
let's do
age
comma
visits
so look at the different format in here
we have one to three so we've done this
by slicing by an integer value and then
on here i've done df2 age comma visits
in an array and when i run this
you can see that we get just these two
columns on here we get agent visits so
it's a quick way to select just two
columns or select number of columns
you're working with
and if you stop there we did the slicing
almost identical to slice is i location
which uses the integer location one
comma three
there's a push in pandas to move to this
particular setup
instead of doing just a regular slice
and that's because this can be confusing
when we slice one to three and then we
select age and visits
so there is a push to go ahead and move
to an eye location which does the same
thing you can see here bc it's the same
as up above there's also copy command so
we can do df3 equals df2 copy we're just
going to create a straight copy of it
and of course if we do df3
it'll be the same as a df2 on there so
df3 equals df2.copy
and then let's do df3 dot is null so
we're looking for null values
and this will return a nice map and
you'll see that everything is false
except when you go up here under the cat
or h they had a null there and so if we
go to have a couple up here also
underneath of let's see the dog okay
there's a bunch of nulls in here there's
d up here so let's look at d down here
and you'll see false true there it is
there's our null value so we can create
a quick chart of null values you can use
this to do other things we can leverage
that null value to maybe take an average
or something and fill those null spaces
with data and we can also modify the
location so here's our df3
location
and notice this is location not i
location ilocation has i for integer
location uses the
in this case the variables on the left
and what we can do on here and we'll go
and just set this equal to
1.5
and then let's um i'll pick a spot let's
go back up here where we had let's do f
a just let's see what are we looking at
oh here we go let's do f and h
and up here f is set to age of 2.0 and
we find out that that's incorrect data
so we go ahead and switch to df3 equal
and then we're going to print out our
df3
and if we go to f and h it is now 1.5 so
we're just changing the value in the df3
and this is changing the actual data
frame remember a lot of our stuff we do
a slice
and like it returns another data frame
this changes the actual data frame and
that value in the data frame
so we've covered location and i location
is null making a copy here's our eye
location which is equivalent of a slice
and also selecting columns
so now we want to dive just take a
little detour here and let's look at df3
means and this is kind of nice because
you can do this you can either do this
by as you can select a single column
here by the way you can just add the
column selection right here like we did
before
so we could have age
look up the mean that just creates a
series if i run that there's our age
but if i take that out instead of
selecting it we can do the whole set up
and it has age and visits so why doesn't
it have priority or animal
well those are not integers so it's
really hard
they're non-numerical values so what is
the average i guess you could do a
histogram which probably will look at
that later on but the only two things we
can really look at is age and visits and
we have
the average or the mean on the age is
3.375
and the mean on visits is 1.9
and let's do df3
visits we'll go and still the visits
again
and remember all those different
functions we looked at for a series well
we can do those here we can do the sum
so if we run that we'll see that these
sum up to 19. we could also look up
minimum if you remember that from before
the minimum is 1
max
so all that functionality is here
i'll just go back to summing it up and
adding it all together so real quick
we've shown you how to take the series
operations and put them into the data
frame and then we can actually this is
interesting one we can just do df3 sum
run and you'll see the different
summations on there
it just combines them i like the way it
just combines the strings on there for
priority and animal we've looked at is
null we've also looked at copying along
with the different slices which we
talked about earlier so let's talk about
strings let's dive into the string setup
on there and let's go ahead and create a
string series string equals pd series
and we just put it right in there we
have a c d a a b a c a popped in a null
value
cow and al i don't know why they picked
cal and al in the background someone
must like those animals and of course we
can just do string if we run that you'll
see leave the r out we'll get an error
but if we put it in there you'll see
that we have a simple series 0 a 1 c 2 d
and it automatically indexes it 0 to 8.
and then we can go string dot lower so
when we're talking about
our data frame in this case or our data
series string in this case we use the
string
function str and we're going to make it
lower and if we go ahead and put the
brackets on there and you'll see that
we've gone from capital a capital c so
on to abc and baca cba cow al they were
all lower case already and of course if
you want to go lower you can also do
upper we'll go ahead and run that
and you can see we now have acd aaa baca
everything's capitalized except for the
null value which is still null all right
so we looked at a few basic string you
can see that string functions upper and
lower
we're going to jump into a very
important topic i'm even going to give
it its own header on here because it's
such an important topic what do you do
with missing values
panda has some great tools for that so
we'll dive into those
we'll call we'll work with df4 and if
you remember the df copy from above
we're just going to make a copy of df3
and let's just take a quick look at the
data we're working with oops df3 forgot
the three on there there we go
so here we have our cats snakes and dogs
hopefully not all in the same container
because that would be just probably mean
to all of them so we made a copy we're
going to be working with df4 and the
reason we made a copy is we want to go
ahead and fill the data and we just
simply do fill in a and then we're going
to give it the value we want to put in
there we'll give it the value 4. so i
can run in here and you'll see now that
df4
now has where the n a was it's filled
with a value of 4. same thing down here
a lot of times we'll compute the mean
first so i might do a mean
age
equals df4
and then we want to go ahead and do age
and dot mean
and then i'll do something like this df4
i only want to select the age and i want
to fill that
with the mean
h
and i run in there and you'll see that
our df4h now has the means in there just
a quick way of showing you how you can
combine these let me go back to our
original one there we go and run that
and keeping with good practices df5
equals df3 dot copy
and we'll print our df5 which should be
the original one
and then on the df5 we can now drop our
missing data
i'm going to simply drop n a and we're
going to use how equals any so i'm going
to drop any row that has missing data in
it and you'll see we had d here with
missing data and h
and then let's go ahead and see what df5
looks like when we do that
there we go and there it is d is gone
and so is h so we create a new data
frame off of this missing those values
now if you have a lot of data dropping
values is a good way to take care of it
because you don't miss some data if you
have not a whole lot of data you're
working with like the iris data set or
something like that or something small
you want to start trying to find a way
to fill that data in so you don't lose
your computational power of the data you
got
so just a quick look at processing null
values
or missing values you can fill them
usually with the means some people use
medium or the mode there's different
ways you can fill it one way is means
and we can also just drop those rows
those are the two main things we do with
missing data
here we go uh we're going to cover next
this is i'd so love data frames for this
file operations
it saved me so much time because they
have so many different tools for
bringing data in and saving data
so we're looking at the data frame file
operations it's really streamlined i
don't know how many times they'll go on
to
different data downloads and they'll
have panda download standard on there
just because it's so widely used so
let's start with the most common file is
a csv so we have df3 to csv or animal
and let me just show you what the folder
is going into right now i have some
untitled and a few things in here but
nothing labeled animal so we go ahead
and run this
and this is now saved the animal to
my hard drive and you can now see the
animal folder up here and if i uh let's
do edit with a notepad oh let's open up
with just a regular notepad there we go
or wordpad if i open that up you can see
it's comma separated our titles they
don't have an index on the categories on
the top and the index comma then all the
different data is separated by commas
standard csv file on there and if we're
going to send it to csv and notice the
format is dot 2 underscore csv
and it's just the name of the file we're
sending it to you can also put the
complete path by default it's going to
go whatever the active directory this
program is running on that's why those
other folders are in there so we have
our df3 to csv and then if we're going
to put it in there we want to also get
it back out and we'll call this one df
underscore animal equals pd read
underscore csv
i always have to remember is two
underscore csv and read underscore csv i
always want to do like a capital in
there and not the underscore we're going
in here again it's the active directory
so if i now do print out my df animal
and let's just do the ahead we only want
to look at the first three lines so if i
go ahead and run this
we'll see the first three lines and they
should match up here what we saved to
our csv
so very easy to save and import from our
csv files on here
and it turns out
df3 also has a two excel they actually
have a lot of different formats but you
know old school
excel was real popular for so long still
is we can go ahead and save it as
animal.xlsx
we're going to call the sheet named
sheet1
and then i can also do df we'll call it
animal2 animal 2 and this one's going to
come from and the same format on here
there we go so we still have our animal
xlsx
the sheet1 that's where it's coming from
index columns equals none so we're not
going to we're going to suppress the
indexing on the columns n a values and
it'll just assign that 0 on up on your
indexes so if it says index columns
equals none that's what it does and then
we've added null values because there's
no values in here and we want to just
make sure that they're marked as n a and
we'll go ahead and just print out the
animal animal two there we go and let's
run that let's make this let's just do
the whole thing so we'll go ahead and
run that
and it probably doesn't help that i
completely forgot the read so animal 2
equals pd.read
excel there we go excel so now we go
ahead and run it
and what we expect is happening here we
have the same data frame on here and if
i flick back to my folder you can now
see that we have the animal one of these
is in excel and one of these is a csv on
here and so there's our two file types
on there and they have other formats
these are just the two most common ones
used and i don't know how many times
i've had stuff from excel i need to pull
out if you've ever played with excel
it's a nightmare in the back end because
of the way they do the indexing
so this just makes it quick and easy to
pull in an excel spreadsheet so we
looked at two different ways to bring
data in and save it to files we've
looked at all kinds of different ways of
manipulating our data set and slicing it
and creating it for our data frame let's
get in there for your visualization
always a big thing at the end because
one it lets you check to see what you
did make sure it looks right and then
also if you're going to show somebody
else it makes it very clear what's going
on if they see something visual so this
is where really important part of data
science is
so let's go ahead and bring in our tools
we're going to do import numpy as np we
want to make sure we have our amber sign
matte plot library in line this just
lets jupiter know that we are going to
print it on this page if you're using a
different ide you don't really
necessarily need that but this does help
it displays correctly in jupiter
notebook and if you remember for earlier
we could create a
we're going to call it ts we're going to
create a pandas which are cute cuddly
creatures versus a pandem short for
pandemonium no so we have ts equals pd
series and we're just going to create a
random
setup of 50. we'll do an index we'll set
it equal to the panda's date range today
periods equals 50 so the 50 should match
and i want you to notice something here
i did not import the map plot library
why because it's already in there pandas
already has its built-in connection and
interface with matplot library so you
don't have to import it
and we'll go ahead and do ts
equals ts dot
cumulative sum we're gonna do the
cumulative sum
so a little reformatting there and we'll
go ahead and plot it and let's take a
look at what that looks like
so we have a nice graph here we have the
dates on the bottom we set this up so we
have a nice range between in this case
-4 to looks like about two maybe or one
minus four and one so what we've done
here we plotted a basic series just a
single row of data and we've set our
indexes on there but we can also do the
whole data frame on there and let's see
what that looks like
so first let's go ahead and create the
data frame we have here random numbers
we're going to do 50 by 4 and then we'll
go ahead and create columns a b x and y
just because we can index is the
ts.index on there so we're going to use
the same index as before
just to keep it nice and uniform we've
already generated the dates to go with
it and then we can do just like we did
with the series
we can also do with the data frame
df equals df cumulative sum
so we're going to sum the whole data
frame and then we'll do simply df plot
and let's put that in and let's go ahead
and run this and look how easy and quick
that was to generate a nice graph with
all the different data on there so we
have our shared index we have the shared
columns and then we have the different
data from each one that we can easily
look at and compare so very quick way of
displaying data you can imagine if you
were working in oh i think i mentioned
stock earlier because i've been doing
some analysis of stock lately so you'd
have your date down here and then you
would have stock a stock b stock x y
whatever it is and you can put them all
on one chart and see how they
what they look like next to each other
and this isn't too far off from what
some of those graphs look like and this
is just randomly generated so stock has
a lot of randomness in it which is one
of the reasons i actually play with it
for doing some of my models on for
testing them out
now there are a lot of features in
pandas so we're going to show you one
more thing on here there's some of the
things like i didn't go too deep we
looked at the top two for importing data
from a csv and from an excel spreadsheet
showed you how to quickly plot the data
there's more settings in there you can
do we're going to do one more thing down
here and this is kind of a fun one
change this to a markdown and run that
so how would you remove repeated data
using pandas
and this is where you have a data set
that comes in and maybe it's feeding
from one location and instead of noting
that it's repeated the date like oh
let's go back to stocks that's a good
visual we have the stocks from the 23rd
and it adds another row and it's the
same row it's importing the 23rd again
and again so now you have that data
repeated three times and you need to go
back and figure out how to get rid of it
how do you track that down
so let's start by creating a quick
database or data frame not a database i
keep saying databases a data frame and
we'll just make this data frame has
using our dictionary going in this data
frame only has one data series in it
which is fine so if we do df to print it
out you'll see a
one two two two two four five four five
six seven so on so how would you remove
that well there is a neat feature in
data frames called shift
along with another feature that lets us
select just certain date information and
we'll go with
the location function put that in
brackets remember that from above
location and then in the location let me
just spread this out a little bit so
it's really easy to read in fact i'm
going to go upscale on that since we're
doing some a little bit more complicated
here
what you can see on this on the location
is i have dfa dot shift so this is going
to shift up one by default you can
actually change this to two or three you
can even do a minus one and it shifts
the other way but it's going to shift up
by 1 by default that's going to say if
that does not equal
df of a
then we want that if you look down here
we had 1 2 2 2 2 2 when we run this
logic on here and we do the shift
it now gets rid of all the duplicates so
we went from one two two two two four
four five whatever it was here it is one
two two two four four four five five
five six six six two one two four five
six seven eight
and you'll see on the index it just
deletes them out of there so the index
stays the same obviously you don't want
the dates to change if you're working
with an index dated setup so it just
deletes those duplicates out of there
this is just a quick way to introduce
you to one the fact that you can add
logic gates into here and two the eye
location
allows you to use shift so there's the
shift function and then the i location
selects that based on true or false
wow so we've actually covered a lot
today in pandas we've really covered
into the basics of selecting your
different series out of your column out
of your data frame how to index rows how
to slice how to plot hopefully you'll
take this beyond that and start
combining these different things and you
can create long strings and really
explore your data generate some nice
graphs if you're in jupiter notebook
it's a great demo to show others
and i didn't know this about jupiter
notebook you can do this in jupyter
notebook and then you can download and i
always i never really look too closely
at all the downloads
but you know it is an html and posted to
your blog so it's got a neat feature in
there but any of this is really powerful
tool all of this is really powerful
tools for doing your data science so
let's start with what is numpy numpy is
the core library for scientific and
numerical computing in python it
provides high performance
multi-dimensional array object and tools
for working with arrays and i'll go a
step further and say there are so many
other modules in python built on numpy
so the fundamentals of numpy are so
important to latch onto for the python
so you can understand the other modules
and what they're doing number's main
object is a multi-dimensional array it's
a table of elements usually numbers all
of the same type indexed by a tuple of
position integers in numpy dimensions
are called axes
take a one-dimensional array or we have
remember dimensions are also called axes
you could say this is the first axis
zero one two three four five and you can
see down here it has a shape of six why
because there's six different elements
in it in the one dimension array and
they usually denote that as six comma
with an empty node on there and then we
have a two dimensional array where you
can see zero one two three four five six
seven and in here we have two axes or
two dimensions and the shape is 2 4. so
if you were looking at this as a matrix
or in other mathematical functions you
can see there's all kinds of importance
on shape we're not going to cover shape
today but we will cover that in part 2.
did you know that numpy's array class is
called nd array for numpy data array now
we're going to take a detour here
because we're working in python and two
of my favorite tools in python is the
jupiter notebook and then i like to use
that sitting on top of anaconda and if
you flip over to jupiter.org that's
j-u-p-y-t-e-r dot org you can go in here
you can install it off of here if you
don't want to use the anaconda notebook
but this is the jupiter setup the
documentation on the jupiter jupiter
opens up in your web browser that's what
makes it so nice is it's portable the
files are saved on your computer they do
run in ipython or iron python and you
can create all kinds of different
environments in there which i'll show
you in just a minute i myself like to
use anaconda that's www.anaconda.com
if you install anaconda it will install
the jupiter notebook with the anaconda
separate and you can install jupiter
notebook and it'll run completely
separate from anaconda's jupiter
notebook and you can see here i've now
opened up my anaconda navigator what i
like about the navigator and this is a
fresh install on a new computer which is
always nice i can launch my jupyter
notebook from in here i can bring other
tools so the anaconda does a lot more
and under environments i only have the
one environment and i can open up the
terminal specific to this environment
this one happens to have python37 in it
the most current version as of this
tutorial and then you open the terminal
if you're going to do your pip installs
and stuff like that for different
modules you can also create different
environments in here so maybe you need a
python36 python35 you can see we're
having a nice framework like anaconda
really helps so you don't have to track
that on your own in the jupyter notebook
and your different jupyter notebook
setups we'll go ahead and launch this
jupyter notebook and then i've set my
browser window for a default of chrome
so it's going to open up in chrome and
you can see here this opens up a folder
on my computer we have a couple
different options on here remember i set
the environment up as python 3.7 you
would install any additional modules
that aren't already installed in your
python on this and it keeps them
separate so you do have to for each
environment install the separate modules
so they match the environment on there
and in here we have a couple things
where you can look up what's running you
have your different clusters again this
is i just installed this on a new
machine so i just have the one a couple
things in here that were run on here
recently and when we go on here is we
then have on the upper right new and
from the pull down menu you'll see
python 3 and this will open up a new
window
and now we're in jupiter
python so this is a python window and
we'll just do a print
and this of course is let's go hello
world
and we'll run that and it prints out
hello world in the command line there's
a couple special things you have to know
we're not going to do today which is on
graphics if you've never seen this
one of the things you can do you can
also do a equals hello world and if you
just put the a in there now if you do a
bunch of these where you have a equals
hello world b equals goodbye world and
you put a b a and return b it'll only
run the last one but you can see here if
you put the variable down here it will
show you what's in that variable
and that has to do with the jupiter
notebook inline coding so that's not
basic python that's just jupiter
notebook shorthand which you'll see in a
little bit
so back to our numpy numpy array versus
python list python list being the basic
list in your python why should we use
numpy array when we have python list
well first it's fast the numpy array has
been optimized over years and years by
multiple programmers and it's usually
very quick compared to the basic python
list setup it's convenient so has a lot
of functionality in there that's not in
the basic python list and it also uses
less memory so it's optimized both for
speed and memory use
and let's go ahead and jump into our
jupyter notebook since we're coding best
way to learn coding is to code just like
the best way to learn how to write is
right and the best way to learn how to
cook is cook so let's do some coding
here today and just like any modules we
have to import numpy we almost always
import it as np that is such a standard
so you'll see that very commonly we can
just run that and now we have access to
our numpy module inside our python and
then the most common thing of course is
to go and create a number array
and in here we can send it a regular
list
and so we'll go ahead and send this a
regular array uh let's do one two three
to make it simple and then i'm just
going to type in a and we'll run this
as you can see down here the output is
an array of one two three and we could
also do
print
just a reminder that this is an inline
command so that wouldn't work if you're
using a different editor you can see
that it's an array one two three but
we'll go and leave it as a
kind of a nice feature so you can see
what you're doing really quick in the
jupyter notebook
and just like all your other standard
arrays i can go
a of 0
which is going to be a value of 1.
of course we do a of 1. you go all the
way through this
a have one has a value of 2 in it
so whether using the numpy array or the
basic python list that's going to be the
same that should all look pretty
familiar and be pretty straightforward
remember the first value is always 0.
and when we set on there so let's take a
look why we're using numpy because we
went over the slide a little bit but
let's just take a look and see what that
actually looks like
and what we want to look at is the fact
that it's fast convenient and uses less
memory so let's take a glance at that in
code and see what that actually looks
like when we're writing it in python and
what the differences are
and to do this i'm going to go ahead and
import a couple other modules we're
going to import the time module so we
can time it and we're going to import
the system module so that we can take a
look at how much memory it uses and
we'll go and just run those so those are
imported
so we'll do b equals oh range of one
yeah one thousand is fine
and so that's going to create a list of
one thousand zero to nine hundred ninety
nine remember it starts at zero and it
stops right at the one thousand without
actually going to the one thousand
and let's go ahead and print
and we want system dot get size of
and we'll pick any integer because we
have you know zero to
a thousand we'll just throw one in there
five it doesn't matter because it's
gonna whatever integer we put in there's
gonna generate the same value because
we're looking the size of how how much
memory it stores an integer in and then
we want to have the link of the b that's
how many integers are in there
and if we go ahead and execute this and
run this in a line we'll see
oops i did that wrong comma
if we multiply them together
we'll see it generates 28 000 so that's
the size we're looking at is 28 000 i
believe that's bytes that sounds about
right
so let's go ahead and create this in
numpy
and we'll go to c equals np and this is
a range
so that's the numpy command do the same
thing that we were just doing in a list
and we'll also use the same value on
there the 1000
and then once we've created the
c
value of c for np dot a range let's go
ahead and print
and we can do that by doing c dot size
times
c dot
item size
that's very similar we did before we did
get the size of so the c size is the
size of the array and each item size
just reversed
so it's the size of an integer five item
size is going to be the integers and c
size and let's just take a look and see
what that generates
and wow okay we got 4000 versus 28 000.
that's a significant difference in
memory how much memory we're using with
the array and then let's go ahead and
take a look at speed let's do um oh
let's do size we tried this with lower
values and it would happen so fast that
the npra kept coming up with zero
because it just rounded it off
so size and let's create an l1
poles
range of size
and we'll do an l2
we'll just set up to the same thing it's
also range
of size on there there we go
and then we can do on a1
equals
np dot
a range size
and then let's do an a
2 equals np dot
a range
we'll keep it the same size
and what we're going to do is we're
going to take these two different arrays
and we're going to perform some basic
functions on them
but let's go ahead and just load these
up now we'll go ahead and run this so
those are all set in memory
except for the typo here
quickly fix that
there we go so these are now all loaded
in here and let's do a start
equals
time dot time
so it's just going to look at my clock
time and see what time it is
and we'll do result equals and let's do
let's say we got
an array and we're going to say
let's do some addition here x
plus y
for x comma y
in
and we'll zip it up here
two different arrays so here's our two
different arrays we're going to multiply
each of the individual things on here
l1
l2
there we go so that should add up each
value so l1 plus l2 each value in each
array
then we want to go ahead and
print and let's say
python list took
and then we'll do
time
dot time
we'll just subtract the start out of
there so time whoops i messed up on some
of the quotation marks on there
okay there we go
time
minus the start
and we'll convert that to seconds so
we'll go uh because in milliseconds or
times one thousand
and let's hit the run on there this is
kind of fun because you also get a view
while we're doing this
of some ways to manipulate the script
and as you can see also my bed typing
there we go okay so we'll go ahead and
run this
and we can see here that the python list
took 34
actually i have to go back and look at
the conversion on there but you can see
it takes roughly 0.34 of a second and we
go ahead and print the result in here
too
let's do that
we'll run that just so you can see what
the what kind of data we're looking at
and we have the zero two four six eight
so it's just adding them together it
looks pretty straightforward on there
and if we scroll down to the bottom of
the answer again we see python list took
46 a little different time on there
depending on what um
core because i have this is on an eight
core computer so it just depends on what
core it's running on what else is
pulling on the computer at the time and
let's go back up here and do our start
time paste that into here
and this time we're going to do a result
equals and this is really cool notice
how elegant this is so straightforward
this is a lot of reason people started
using numpy is because i can add the two
arrays together by simply going a1 plus
a2
makes a lot of sense both looking at it
and it's just very
convenient remember that slide we're
looking at fast convenient and less
memory so look how convenient that is
really easy to read real easy to see
and i don't know if we don't need to
print the result again so let's just go
ahead and print
the time on here
and we'll borrow this from the top part
because i really am a lazy type
and this isn't the python list this is
the numpy list or number array
and let's go ahead and see how that
comes out
and we get 2.99
so let's take a look at these two
numbers 46 versus 2.99 so we'll just
round this up to three that's a huge
difference that's that's like
more than 10 times faster that's like 15
times roughly at a quick glance i'd have
to go do the math to look at it and it's
going to vary a little bit depending on
what's running in the background the
computer obviously so we've looked at
this and if we go back here we found out
it's much faster
yes there's different going to be
different speeds depending on what
you're doing with the array very
convenient easy to read and it uses less
memory so that's the core of the numpy
that's why a lot of people base so many
other modules on numpy and why it's so
widely used
so we did glance at a couple operations
when we were looking at speed and size
let's dive into a little bit more into
the basic operations
and these are always nice to see i mean
certainly you want to go get a cheat
sheet if you're using it for the first
time you know look things up google is
your friend we did this with the most
basic numpy dot array or np.array
and we'll go ahead and create an array
let's do
pairs
one comma two
and then let's do a three comma four and
if we're gonna do that let's do five
comma six
there we go and if we go ahead and take
this
and run this i can go ahead and do our a
down here so it's in line and i'll print
that out
you can see it makes a nice array for us
so we have a and if you look at that we
have three different objects each with
two values in them and hopefully you're
starting to think well how many
dimensions or indexes is that and you'll
see three by two so let's go ahead and
take a look and let's go how about a dot
in dimensions speaking of which
we'll run that and we have two
dimensions for each object
and then we can do the item size so a
dot
we saw this earlier we looked up how
many items it was up here where we
wanted to multiply item size times the
actual size of the object so the memory
is being used versus the item size
and we should see four there
memory is compressed down that's always
a good thing and then the shape the
shape is so
important when you're working with data
science and you're moving it from
one format to another
so we have our shape we just talked
about that we have three by two three
rows by two objects in each one
generally i don't look too much at the
size but the dimensions i'm always
looking up this is nice you can automate
it so you might be converting something
you might need to know how many
dimensions are going into the
next machine learning package so that
you can automatically just have it send
that information over
so we looked at a shape
let's go and create a slightly different
array np dot array let's go ahead and
just do as our original
set up here
and one of the features we can do which
is really important is we can do d type
equals in this case let's do
np
float
64. and so what we've done is converting
all of these into a float and we've
typed in a
and now instead of having one two three
four five six you see they're all float
values one dot zero there's no actual
zero in there just here's the one dot or
the one period two three period four
period five period six period
and this again data science i don't know
how many times i've had to convert
something from an integer to a float so
that's going to work correctly in the
model i'm using
so very common features to be aware of
and to be able to get around and use
and we'll also do let's just curiosity
item size
we'll go and run that
and we see that it doubled in size so
it's not a huge increase well doubling
is always a big increase in computers
but it's not a huge increase compared to
what it would be if you're running this
in the python list format
and then we did the shape earlier
without having it set to the float64
let's go ahead and do a shape with it
set to 64. and it should be the same
three comma two so it all matches
so we've gone through and remember if
you really if this is all brand new to
you
according to the cambridge study at the
cambridge university
if you're learning a brand new word in a
foreign language the average person has
to repeat it
163 times before it's memorized
so a lot of this you build off of it so
hopefully you don't have to repeat it
163 times but we did manage to repeat it
at least twice here if not a little bit
more
and let's go ahead and take this we're
going to look at one more setup on here
and let me just take this last statement
here on the converting our properties of
our data
and instead of float 64
let's do complex let's just see what
that looks like and let's go and print
that out and run it
and so we now have a complex data set up
and you'll see it's denoted by the one
dot plus zero dot j
and if we flip over here and do a basic
search for numpy data types
better to go to the original web page
but pull up a bunch of these you can see
there's a whole list of different numpy
data types
shorthand complex we have complex
complex 64 complex 128 complex number
represented by 264-bit floats real and
imaginary components
one option on there float 16 float32
float shorthand for float64 most
commonly used and of course all the
different ones that you can possibly put
into your numpy array so we covered a
basic addition up there we're comparing
how fast it runs but some very basic
components how to set up a numpy array
how many dimensions it has item size
data type item again we went to item
size and there's also
the
shape probably one of the more used i
used a shape all the time very commonly
used
and then down here you can see where we
actually created a numpy complex data
type
so let's look at some other features in
numpy one of them is you could do numpy
dot
zeros
and we're gonna do three comma four
there we go and we'll go ahead and run
this and you can see if i do np dot
zeros i create a numpy array of zeros
this is really important i was
rebuilding my own neural network and i
needed to create an array where i
initialized the weights and i want them
all to be the same weight in this case i
wanted them to start off as zero for the
particular project i was working on and
there's other options like you can do
numpy
ones
and we'll do the same thing three comma
four we'll run that
and you can see i've created a an array
of numpy ones in this case it comes out
as a float array
and this is an interesting to note
because we have let's go back to our
python and do lrange5
and we'll print the l so as our list
and if i run that
it doesn't create the range until after
the fact until you actually execute it
that's an upgrade in python python27
actually created the array zero one two
three four this one actually creates the
script and then once it's used it then
actually generates the array
and if we do that in numpy a range
remember that from before
and if we do numpy a range 5
and let's do l equals
or we can just leave it as numpy that's
fine there we go just run that
you can see there we actually get an
array zero one two three four for the
value the numpy arrange a range five
generates the actual array
and for part one we're going to do just
one more section on basic
setup
and we're going to concatenation
do a concatenation out example
there we go we're going to do strings
let's take a look at uh strings what's
going on with there and let's do
oh let's see print
let's do an np
character something new here
and we're going to add
and then here's our brackets for what
we're going to add
oh and let's say
let's do
hello
comma hi
and
in the brackets on there let's create
another one
and this one's going to be
and we'll do
x y z so we're just creating something
randomly making some up on here and then
we'll go ahead and just print this
if we run that and come down here
and of course make sure all your
brackets are open and closed correctly
and then you can see in here when we
concatenate the example in numpy
it takes the two different arrays that
we set up in there and it combines the
hello with the abc and the high with xyz
and if we can also do something like
print
oh let's do
np character dot
multiply
so there's a lot of different functions
in here again you can look these up it's
probably good to look them all up and
see what they are but it's good to also
just see them in action let's do hello
space comma three
and we'll run this one
and run that without the error you'll
see it does hello hello hello so we
multiplied it by three and we can also
let's just take this whole thing here
instead of retyping it
and we can do character
center so instead of multiply let's do
center
and over here
keep our hello going
take the space out of there
and let's do center it 20
and fill character
equals and we'll fill it with dashes
so if we run this
you can see it prints out the hello with
dashes on each side and we keep going
with that we can also in addition to
doing the fill function we can play with
capitalize we can title we can do
lowercase we can do uppercase we can
split split line strip join these are
all the most common ones and let's go
ahead and just look at those and see
what those look like each one of them
here we're going to do the hello world
all-time favorite of mine i always like
to say hello universe and you can see
here we did a capital h with the world
but so we want to capitalize so
capitalize is the first one in the array
so we get hello world on there and we
can also take this and instead of
capitalizing
another feature in here is title and
let's just change this to how are we
doing
how
are you doing instead of do do you and
let's run that
and you can see here because we created
it as a title it capitalizes the first
letter in each word
and in this one we're going to do
character lower
two different examples here we have an
array we have hello world all
capitalized and we have just hello and
you can see that one is an array and one
is just a string if we run that
you get a an array with hello world
lowercase and hello lower case
and if we're going to do it that way we
can also do it the opposite way there's
also upper
and let's paste those in there and you
can see here we have
character.upper opposite there
python.data and that will do python is
easy
hopefully you're starting to get the
picture that most of the python and the
scripting is very simple
it's when you put the bigger picture
together and starts building these
puzzles and somebody asks you hey i need
the first letter capitalized unless it's
the title and then we have you start
realizing that this can get really
complicated so numpy just makes it
simple and we like that
and so in this case we did python data
it's all uppercase python is easy like
shouting in your messenger python is
easy
and then if you're ever processing text
and tokenizing it
a lot of times the first thing you do is
we just split the text and we're just
going to run
character this
split are you coming to the party if we
do that returns an array of each of the
individual words are you coming to the
party splitting it by the spaces
and then if we're going to split it by
spaces we also need to know how to split
it by
lines and just like we have the basic
split command we also have split lines
hello and you'll see here the scoop in
for our new line
and when we run that if you're following
the split part with the words you should
see hello how are you doing the two
different lines are now split apart
and let's just review three more before
we wrap this up commonly used string
variable manipulations we have strip and
in this case we have
nina admin anita and we're going to
strip a off of there let's see what that
looks like
and then you end up with nin diminish it
basically takes up all leading and
trailing letters in this case we're
looking for a
more common would be a space in there
but it might also be punctuation or
anything like that that you need to
remove from your letters and words
and if we're going to strip and clean
data we also need to be able to reformat
it or join it together so you see here
we have a character join we'll go ahead
and run this
and it has on the first one it splits
these letters up by the colon and the
second one by the dash and you can see
how this is really useful if you're
processing in this case a date we have
day month year year month date very
common things to be have to always
switch around and manipulate depending
on what they're going into and what
you're working with
and finally let's look at one last
character string
we're going to do replace
if you're doing misinformation this is
good pulling news articles and replacing
is and what in this case we're just
doing here's a good dancer and we're
going to replace is with was
and you can see here he was a good
dancer hopefully that's not because he
had a bad fall he just was from like you
know 1920s and has gotten old
so there we go we covered a lot of the
basics in numpy as far as creating an
array
very important stuff here when you're
feeding it in how do we know the shape
of it the size of it what happens we
convert it from a regular integer into a
float value as far as how much space it
takes we saw that that doubled it item
size you have your n dimensions and
probably the most used is shape and
we'll cover more on shape in part two so
make sure you join us on part two
because a lot of important things on
shaping in there and setting them up we
also saw that you can create a
zeros based array you can create one
with ones if we do a range you can see
how it is a lot easier to use to create
its own range or a range as it is in
numpy
you saw how easy it was to add two
arrays we saw that earlier just plus
sign then we got into
doing strings and working with strings
and how to concatenate so if you have
two different arrays of strings you can
bring them together we also saw how you
can fill so you can add a nice headline
dash dash dash well we saw about
capitalize the first letter we saw about
turning it into a title so all the first
letters are capitalized doing lower case
on all the letters upper for all the
letters just lower and upper nice
abbreviation we also covered how to
split the character set how to strip it
so if you want to strip all the a's out
from leading ai a's and ending a's or
spaces you can do that very easily also
how to join the data sets so here's a
character join option for your strings
and finally we did the character replace
let's go ahead and dive in part two
which is getting some coding going under
our belt and here in our jupiter
notebook we can go under new and create
a new folder python 3.
i think i forgot to do this last time we
could just do the
control plus plus which in any browser
enlarges the page makes it a lot easier
to see always a nice feature another
beautiful benefit of using jupyter
notebook
and let me go ahead and show you a neat
thing we can do in jupiter this is nice
if you're working with people and you're
doing this as a demo on a large screen
i'm going to do the hashtag or pound
symbol array manipulation kind of a
title that we're working on and then i'm
going to call this cell cell type
marked down as opposed to code and
you'll see it highlights it here and
then if i run it it just turns it into
array manipulation and then we're
specifically going to be working on
array manipulation changing shape to
start with
and we'll go ahead and mark this cell
also a markdown so has a nice little
look there and then it comes up and you
can see it just like i said it just
highlights it and makes it very in bold
print just making it easier to read not
a python thing but a jupiter thing
that's good to know about especially if
you're working with the shareholders
since they're investing money in you
of course the first thing we do is
import we're going to import numpy
as in p that should be standard by now
by now you you start a python program
you're doing some data science numpy is
just something you bring in there and
let's go ahead and create our array and
we're going to do that as the np
dot a range remember that's a 0 where
we're going to do 0 to 9
and then we'll go print
a little title on the original array
we'll just print that array a remember
from the first lesson so we have our
array which is 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8.
and let's add a print space in between
let's create a second array b but we
want this to reshape array a
and what does that mean
and the command is simply reshape and
then we have nine items in here and this
is so important right now so be very
aware if i did some weird numbers in
here it's not going to work and we want
multiples of 9 we know that 3 times 3 is
9.
so we're going to reshape
our a array by 3x3 and then we're going
to print well let's give it a title
oops i have too many brackets in there
modified array and then let's go ahead
and print
our b
and let's see what that looks like
and as we come down here you can see
we've taken this and it's gone from
0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 to an array of arrays
and we have zero one two three four five
six seven eight
and so we split this into three by three
and you can guess that if i tried to
reshape this let's just do a five by
three which is 15.
that's going to give me an error so it's
not going to work you're not going to be
able to reshape something unless the
shape all the the data in there matches
correctly
so we can take this 9 this flat 9 and
they call it a flex it's just a single
array and we can reshape it into a three
by three array and first you might think
matrixes which this is used for that
definitely i use it a lot in graphing
because they'll come in that i have an
array that's x y comma x y one white one
comma x two y two and so the shape of it
might be two by the length of the number
of points
and i need to separate that into a x
flat ray and a y flat array you can see
this can be very easy to reshape the
array doing that and we can of course go
back we can do b
do a print
and we'll do b dot
latin remember i said it's called a
flatten array
and if we run that
you'll see it just goes back to the
original one it takes this 0 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 and flattens it back to a single
array
and then one other feature to be aware
of is if we flatten it one of the
commands we can put in there is order
let me just go ahead and do that order
equals
f strangely enough f stands for fortran
the whole fortran days i remember
actually studying fortran programming
language
in this case you'll see that it uses the
first like zero three six
as the order so instead of flattening it
like we had before zero one two three
four five six seven eight it now does
zero three six one four seven two five
eight
and if you go to the numpy array page
you can see here that they have the
flattened and you just open up the numpy
and d array flattened setup to look it
up and they have three different options
they have c
f and a
and it's whether to flatten in c which
was based on how the c code works for
flattening originally worked which is
row major
fortran which is column major or
preserve the column fortran ordering
from a so whatever it was in the default
is the c version so the default that you
saw you could put orders equal c and
it'd have the same effect as we saw
there before you could even do order
equals a that would also have the same
effect because that's the default so
really the only other thing you really
need to change on here is to change it
to c if you need it
and you can see right here or f i mean
not c the only thing you really want to
change it to is to your f for the
fortron order which then does it by
column versus by row and let's look at
here we go
reshape
so let's create a range of 12
and let's reshape it
and we'll do 4 comma 3 for this one and
remember this is numpy i forgot the np
there in p dot arrange
and we can type in just a for print or
you can do full print a and of course in
jupyter notebook even have a little
extra print at the beginning we run this
we'll see we create a nice array of 0
one two it's reshaped it so we have
four rows and three columns or you could
call that three columns and four rows
zero one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven
but this one is so important we'll do np
transpose
a let's go ahead and run that
and it helps if i get all the s's in
there don't leave an s out and you'll
see here we've taken our array if you
remember correctly we had 0 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11
and we've swapped it so we've gone from
a three by four or a four by three to a
three by four
and this really helps if you're looking
at like a huge number of rows and the
data all comes in like let's say this is
your features in row one your features
in row two
and this is x y z well when you go to
plot it you send it all of x in one
array all the white and not one array in
all z in another array
and so it's really important that we can
transpose this rather quickly
this is kind of a fun thing i can
highlight it and do brackets around it
and if you remember correctly
because we're in jupiter it doesn't
matter whether we do the print or not
it'll automatically print it for us and
you see if i hit the run button it comes
up with the same exact thing
and let's play with the reshape and you
know what let's zoom this up a little
bit here
make that even bigger so you can really
see what's going on and let's play with
the reshape just a little bit more we'll
do b equals
np.a range let's do 8
and
reshape we'll do two comma four
let's go ahead and print b
and then run that
and you'll see we have now the two rows
this is a bit more like so we have four
maybe two rows of four things so this
might be all of our x components and our
y components so we can switch it back
and forth real easy
important to know here whether we do two
comma four or in the case of four comma
three
this has twelve elements and so however
you split it up it's got to equal 12.
so 4 times 3 equals 12 that's pretty
straightforward same thing down here
2 times 4 equals 8.
if i change this and let's say i do 2
comma 3 let's just run that in and
you'll find we get an error because
you can't split eight up into two rows
by three
you have to pick something that it can
split up and arrange it in so let's go
ahead and run that and just for fun
let's go um reshape our b again if i can
type
reshape our b again and what else goes
into eight well we could do two by two
by two
so we can take this out to three
different
dimensions and then of course if we um
because this is going to come out you
you as a variable we can just go ahead
and run it
and it'll print it we can also do a
print statement on there just like we
did before and you'll see we have two
different groups of two variables of two
different dimensions
so two by two by two and let's go ahead
and assign this to a variable c equals b
reshape
and let's do something a little
different
let's roll the axes roll
axes
and we'll take our c
and do two comma one
and if we go ahead and run this it's
going to print that out whoops
hit a wrong button there let's do that
one again and you roll the axis and you
can see that we now have a set of zero
one two three four five six seven we now
have the zero two one three four six
five seven
so what's going on here we're taking and
we're rolling the numbers around and
let's just simplify this we'll just do
it with c comma 1 and run that and so if
we roll a single axis you got 0 1
and then it rolled the 4 5
up and then we have 2 3 6 7 and if we do
two
let me see what happens there this is
one of those things you really have to
play with and start filling what it's
doing
we've now taken 0 2 4 6 1 3 5 7 so you
can see we've now rolled by two digits
instead of rolling the one set up we now
roll two digits up there and so if we go
back and we do the one
so we've rolled it up zero one four five
and then we're gonna take the two in
there and we've rolled the zero one two
three four five and six seven
so we start rolling these things around
on here there's a lot of different
things you can do on this
but it's another way to manipulate the
numbers on your numpy
and finally let's go ahead and
swap axes
we'll do c
and let's just go ahead and run that
it's going to give me an error on there
that's because it requires multiple
arguments left out the arguments so now
we can swap and we get the 0 two one
three four six five seven so you can see
everything's been swapped around
so next thing we wanna go over is we
wanna go over numpy
arithmetic operations
how can we take these and use these let
me just go ahead and put this cell as a
markdown there we go
we'll run that so it has a nice thing
all right nice title on there that's
always helpful
and let's start by creating two arrays
we'll do uh a as an ep np
range a range nine and let's reshape
this
three by three so by now you should be
saying this reshape stuff and this
should all look pretty familiar we have
our zero one two three four five six
seven eight on there and let's create a
second one b
and this time instead of doing a range
let's do np array we'll just create a
straight up array
and we'll do an array of three objects
so it's going to be
three by one and if we go ahead and
print a b out let me run that this is
actually pretty common to have something
like this where you have a three by
whatever it is in a
three by three array when you're doing
your math you kind of have that kind of
setup on there
and what we can do is we can go um
np dot add
a b
don't forget we can always put a print
statement on there so if we add it
you'll see that it just comes in there
and it goes okay we're adding 10 to
everything and we could actually do
something more i'll make it more
interesting 11 10 11 12. so let's change
b's now 10 11 12 and let's run that and
you can see that we have
10 and then you had 1 plus 11 is 12
2 plus 12 is 14
13 so 10 plus 3 is 13 11 plus 4 is 15
and 12 plus 5 is 17 and so on
we'll put this back since that's how the
original setup was let's do 10 by 10 by
10 and run that and run that and get the
original answer and if you're going to
add them together we need to go ahead
and subtract
a b
and we run that
we get minus 10 minus 9 minus 8 just
like you would expect
so we have our subtraction 0 minus 10 is
minus 10 and so on and if you're going
to add and subtract you can guess what
the next one is we're going to multiply
and we'll multiply
a b
and this should be pretty
straightforward you should expect this
if we multiply
10 times 0 we got 0 10 times 10 is 10
and so on
and finally if you're going to multiply
what's the last one we got is divide
what happens we do divide a by b
and we run this
and we're going to get 0
and this is
0 divided by 10 is 0 1 divided by 10 is
0.1 2 divided by 10 is 0.2 and so on and
so on
so the math is pretty straight forward
it just makes it very easy to do the
whole set up and again if we went this
and let's say i'll just change this up
up here instead of 10
we do a hundred
and
make this a thousand there we go
if we run that and then we do the add
you can see we got 10
plus 100 plus a thousand
same thing with the subtract
same thing with the multiply
and then you can also see the same thing
here with the divide so a lot of control
there with your array and your math
again let's set this back to 10 oops
it's right up here wrong section
there we go 10. we'll just go ahead and
run these
and get back to where we were
and this brings us to our next section
which is slicing and let's put in our
just make this a cell
cell type markdown and then we run that
of course it gives us a nice looking
slicing there and slicing means we're
just going to take sections of the array
so let's create an array in p a range
let's just do
20.
and if you remember if we do a
we have a 0 to 19.
and then we can do a and remember you
can always print these this can always
be put in a print but because i'm in
jupiter if you're doing a demo in
jupiter that is it's just so great that
you have all these controls on here so
we can slice four
on and this should look familiar because
this is the same as the python and a lot
of other different scripting languages
if we do four go zero one two three
that's the first four in the thing and a
skip sum and starts with this one the
first four skip then from there on
you can also do the opposite
and go till the fourth one if we run
that we get zero one two three quite the
opposite on there we can do a single
item so we can pick object number five
on the list run that and five happens to
be five because that's the order they're
in and then this one's interesting so i
can do s equals slice
and let's create a slice here
and let's do two comma nine comma
yeah let's leave it two on there so
we'll create an s slice on here and then
if we take our array and we do array of
s we're taking our slice in there and
let's go ahead and run that
and let's take a look and see what it
generated here first off we started with
two so we have two at the beginning
we're going to end at nine which happens
to be eight so it stops before the nine
remember when we're doing arrays in
python and then we step two so two four
six eight
we could do this as three let me run
that and you can see how the changes to
five eight
and we could do this as uh let's leave
this at three and if we change this to
ten
oops let's make it twelve there we go
when we run that we have two five eight
eleven so that's pretty straightforward
it's a very nice feature to have on here
we can slice it
and take different parts of the series
right out of the middle so now that
we've accessed the different pieces of
our array
let's get into iterating iteration and
this is interesting because
my sister who runs a college data
science
division the first question she asks
is
how do you go through data and she's
asking can you do you know how to
iterate through data do you know how to
do a basic for loop you know how to go
through each piece of the data and in
numpy they have some cool controls for
that this is a markdown there we go and
run it
it's called the nd iter i'm not sure
what the nd stands for but ndeiter for
iterator
so before we do that though let's create
an array or something we can actually
iterate through
we'll call it a equals np
a range
let's do something a little funny here
or funky
and we'll do 0 45
5. i'm not sure
why the guys in the back picked this
particular one it's kind of a fun one
and if i run that we do this you can see
we get 0 5 10 15 20 25 30 35 40. that's
what this array looks like
and that's just from our slice you could
this is just a slice that's all that is
is we created a slice of 0.45 0 to 45
step five
and so we can do with this we can also
do a equals the shape let's go ahead and
take and reshape this
and since there's nine variables in
there we'll do a reshape it three by
three so if we run that oops missed
something there that is the a
that really helps
so if we do the a reshape
and we'll go ahead and print that out
we get 0 5 10 15 20 25 30 35 40.
and then we simply do four x in
our numpy indeed
of a
colon and we'll just go ahead and print
x
and let's see what happens here when we
run through this and we print each one
of those
it goes all the way through the whole
array so it's the same thing we just saw
before we got 0 5 10
15 20 25 30 35 40. so it prints out each
object in the array so you can go
through and view each one of these
and certainly if you remember you could
also flatten the array and just do for
a and that also and get the same result
there's a lot of ways to do this but
this is the proper way with the nd
iterator because it'll minimize the
amount of resources needed to go through
each of the different
objects in the numpy array
and hopefully you asked this question
when i just did that
and the question is how can i change
this instead of doing each object so
first of all let's go ahead and take my
cell type and mark that down run it and
so we're going to work on iteration
order c style and f style remember c
because it came from the c programming
and f because it came from the old
fortran programming so let's give us a
reminder i will do a print a
and we'll do 4 x in np
iterate
a but we also want to do this in a
specific order and you know what i'm a
really lazy typer so let's go back up
here
this is the nd iterator i knew i was
missing the nd part of a
let's do order
equals
c
we'll print x on there and let's do that
again and this time order
order equals
f there we go order equals f let's go
ahead and run this
and see what happens here and the first
thing you're going to notice our
original array 0 5 10 15 20 25 30 35 40.
when we do order c that's the default
0 5 10 15 20 and so on and then when you
come down here
you'll see f order f is 0 15 30. so it
takes the first digit of each of the sub
arrays or the second dimension and then
it goes into the second one 5 20 35 10
25 40. so slightly different order for
iterating through it if you need to do
that so we've covered reshaping we
covered math we've covered iteration
we've covered a number of things the
next section we want to go ahead and go
over
is going to be joining arrays so we need
to bring them together let me go ahead
and take the cell and make it a
markdown cell type markdown there we go
and run that so let's work on joining
arrays so we can bring them together and
with different options we have
and let's do we'll do an np array one
two
comma three four
we'll go ahead and print
let's do
oops
first
these rays aren't that big so let's just
go ahead and keep it all on one line a
so if we run this first array one two
three four oops i forgot that it
automatically wraps it when you do it
this way so we'll go ahead and keep it
separate
and print
a there we go
and let's go ahead and do a b
and we'll do five six seven eight and
notice i'm keeping the same shape on
these two arrays
depending on what you're doing those
shapes have to match
and let's go ahead and print
second array
do a print
b
i'm going to run that oops
miss something up there let me fix that
real quick
when i was reformatting it to go on
separate lines i messed that up there we
go run all right so we have first array
one two three four second array five six
seven eight
and we'll put a carriage return on there
and the keyword we use is concatenate
and if you're familiar with linux it
usually means you're adding it to the
end on there and we're going to do what
they call a long axis 0. so we have
concatenate a b along axis zero let's go
ahead and run that and see what that
looks like
so we have one two three four five six
seven eight so now we have an array that
is four by two has a nice shape of four
by two one here
and if we're going to do it along the
axis zero
you should guess what the next one is
we're gonna do it along the one axis and
let's see how those differ from each
other let's just go ahead and run that
and again all we're doing is adding in
the axis equals one so we have our
concatenate we have a b and then axis
one
remember a couple things one these are
the same shape so we have a two by two
same dimensions going in there you're
going to get an error if you're
concatenating and they're not if you
have something that instead of one two
is one two three four five six with a
five six seven eight they'll give you an
error on there in fact let's take a look
and see what happens when we do that let
me just take this
one two three
three four five and let's run that and
if we come down here oh we got there it
says all the input array dimensions
except for the concatenation axes m must
match exactly
so it'll let you know if you mess up
that's always a good thing let's go
ahead and take this back here and let's
go ahead and run that
and so we have our zero axes which is
one two three four five six seven eight
and we bring them together
and you'll see a very different set up
here when we do it along the axis one
we end up with instead of a four by two
we end up with a two by four one two
five six three four seven eight and
that's just changing which axes we're
going to go ahead and concatenate on
what i find is when you're talking about
the concatenate or the joining arrays
you really got to play with these for a
while to make sure you understand what
you mean by the axes
it looks very intuitive when you're
looking at it actually zero
one two three four five six seven eight
axes one is then splitting in a
different way one two five six three
four seven eight
when you're actually using real data you
start to really get a feel for what this
means and what this does
so if we're going to do that let's go
ahead and look at splitting the array
and do that into markdown and run it
there we go so you have a nice little
title there
and we'll go ahead and create an array
of nine
let's do np split
we'll do a and we're gonna split it by
three
let's just see what that looks like so
if we split it we get an array 0 1 2 3 4
5. we have three separate arrays on here
and remember we're looking at let me
just print a up here
so we're looking at 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
and then we can split it into three
separate arrays
and let's take this we're going to do
this right down here just move the a
split down here
instead of the three let's do four comma
five and put that in brackets
and so we do it this way we have zero
one two three
four five six seven eight and that's
kind of interesting i wasn't sure what
to expect on that but we get when you
split it a by four comma five you get a
totally different setup on here as far
as the way it split the array
and to understand how this works i'm
going to change the 5 to a 7
and this will visually make this a
little bit more clear
so we had four and five it went zero one
two three four
five six seven eight and you see the
markers four and five
when we do four and seven i get zero one
two three four five six
seven eight and so what you're looking
at here is the first markers this is
going to go to four
so there's our first split at the four
the marker of four and then the second
split is going to be at position seven
and this is the same thing here
four position five that's why we're
splitting it in those two sections we
could also do it seven let's just see
what that looks like run and you can see
i now have zero one two three four five
six seven eight
so we can split in all kinds of
different ways and create a different
set of
multiple arrays on here and split it all
kinds of different ways
and before we get into the graphs and
other
miscellaneous stuff
let's go ahead and look at
resizing the array i'm going to take
this cell and set the cells a mark down
and run it
give us a nice title there and we'll do
an array uh an input array of one two
three and four five six here let's go
and just print
let's go print
a dot
shape and we'll go ahead and run that
oops hit a wrong button there
hit the comma instead of the dot so we
have a shape of two comma three here
and this is important to note because we
start resizing it it's going to mess
with different aspects of the shape
and so we're gonna do a print
scoop in for a blank line there we go
let's do b equals
np dot resize
we're going to resize a
and let's resize it with three by two
and then we'll just go ahead and
print
b
and print
b period shape not a comma
i'll run that
oops forgot the
quotation marks around the end we'll go
ahead and run that and let's just see
what that looks like so we have
one two three four five six original
array with a shape of two three
and then we want to go ahead and resize
it by three two and we end up with one
two three four five six and we end up
with a shape of three two that shouldn't
be too much of a surprise
you know we got six elements in there we
can resize it by two 3 was the original
one and then we're actually just
reshaping is how that kind of comes out
as when you resize it like that
but what happens if we do something a
little different
and let's go ahead and just take this
whole thing and copy it down here so we
see what that looks like
and instead of doing 3 2 remember last
time i did the
to reshape it
i messed with the numbers and it gave me
an error when you resize it you don't
have to match the numbers they don't
have to be the same dimensions so we can
instead of going from a 2 3 to a 3 2 we
can resize it to a 3 3.
so let's take a look and see how it
handles that and we come down here to 3
3 we end up with one two three four five
six and it repeats one two three
so it actually takes the data and just
adds a whole other block in there based
on the original data and repeating it
all right now at this point you know
we've been looking at tons of numbers
and moving stuff around we want to go
ahead and do is get a little visual here
because that
certainly you can picture all the
different
numbers on there but let's look at
histogram
let's put this into a histogram let me
go ahead and run that
and to do that we're going to use the
matte plot library so from map plot
library we're going to import pi plot as
plt
that's usually the notation you see for
pi plot
so if you ever see plt in a code it's
probably pi plot in the matplot library
and then the guys in the back did a nice
job and gals too guys and gals back
there
our team over at simply learn put
together a nice array for me 20 87 4 40
53 with a bunch of numbers that way we
had something to play with
and we want to do is we wanted to plot
the histogram remember a histogram says
how many times
different numbers come in and then we're
going to put them in bins and we have
been 0 to 20 to 40 to 60 to 80 to 100.
you might in here with the matplot
library they call them bins you might
hear the term buckets where they put
them in buckets it's a really common
term
then we want to give it a title so the
way it works is you do your plt.hist for
histogram your plt title and your plt
show
and we're doing just a single array in
here in the numpy array of a and let's
go ahead and run this piece of code
taking a moment to come out there says
figure size so it's generating the graph
and you can see we have let's just take
a look at this and go down a size there
we go okay so now we can see we're
taking a look at here
so between 0 and 20
we have three values so we have a 20
here we have a 4
and a 11 and a 15.
0 1 2 3. it's actually four values but
they start at zeros remember we always
count from zero up
and from 20 to 40 we got 20 this is 1 42
5 6.
and so you can see in the histogram it
shows that the most common numbers
coming up
is going to be between the 40 and 60
range least common between the 80 and
100 this looks like a age demographics
is what this looks like to me and you
can see where they would have put it in
the buckets of different age groups
which would be a nice way of looking at
this
histograms are so important so powerful
when you're doing
demos and explaining your data so being
able to quickly put a histogram up that
shows
what's common and how it's trending is
really important
and using that with a numpy
is really easy
and you know what let's take the same
data and i want to show you why we do
bins or why we have buckets of data i'm
used to calling it buckets why we have
bins let's do it instead of by 20 let's
do it by tens and see what happens
and what happens when you do it by tens
is you miss out on the you can see a
nice curve here on the first one and on
the second one it looks like a ladder
going up and a plummet a ladder going up
and a plummet and a ladder going down
so the first would be more indicative of
an age group and the second one would be
what you would get if you divide it
incorrectly you wouldn't see the natural
trend of
i don't know what this would be maybe
how much food they eat hopefully not
because i'm in 50 so i'm right in the
middle there that which means i get a
ton of food compared to everybody else
but it's some kind of democrat maybe
it's mental maybe it's knowledge because
we we hit a certain point and we start
losing our marbles start leaking out or
something so you start off knowing
something and then as you get older you
grow more but you can see here we lose
that you lose that continuity in the
thing if you split the histogram into
too many bins or too many buckets
and if you actually plotted this by the
individual numbers it would just be a
bunch of dots
on the graph it wouldn't mean a whole
lot
and we've looked at graphs there are
terms that are a ton of useful functions
in
i'm sure there's even new ones that are
going to be in here but let's just cover
some important ones you really need to
know about if you're using the numpy
framework
one of them is line space function this
is generating data so we have a line
space we have 1 3 10 and when we do that
we end up with
10 numbers so if you count them there's
10 numbers they're between 1 and 3 and
they're evenly spaced we get 1 1.222 but
these are all there's a total of 10 here
and it's right between the 1 and 3 range
that can be there's a lot of uses for
that but they're probably more obscure
than a lot of the other common numpy
arrays set up
a real common one is to do summation so
we'll do summation
where you do in this case we create a
numpy array of one of um
two different arrays one two three or
two different dimensions one two three
three four five
and we're going to sum them up under
axes 0 which is your columns
and if you remember correctly columns is
the 1 plus 3 2 plus 4 3 plus 5 so we
have 3 columns
and if we change this we'll just flip
this to 1.
we get two numbers so we get one two
three all added together which equals
six and three plus four plus five which
equals twelve we'll set this back to
zero
there we go since it was just we're
looking to actually zero
and these probably could have been some
of these communities with our math
section
square root and standard deviation two
very important
tools we use throughout the machine
learning process
and data science
and simply we take the np array we have
again the one two three four five six
three four five i don't know why i need
to keep recreating it probably could
just kept it but we can take the square
root of a so it goes through and it
takes the square root of all the
different terms in a
and we can also take the standard
deviation how much they deviate in value
on there
and there's a rabble function we can run
that
and np array is x we're going to do x
equals say we changed it from a to x
x equals
ravel and this sets it up as columns so
we have one two three four five this is
all columns on here very similar to the
flattened function
so they kind of look almost identical
but we also the option of doing a ravel
by column
and then another one is log so you can
do mathematical log on your array in
this case we have 1 2 3
and we'll find the
log base 10 for each of those three
numbers
there's a couple of them they don't you
can't just do any number here after log
but there is also log base 2.
log base 10 is pretty commonly used on
here
there we go
before we go let's have a little fun
let's do a little practice session here
on some more challenging questions so
you start to think how this stuff fits
together right now we just looked at all
the basics and all the basic tools you
have
so let's do some numpy practice examples
and let's start by figuring out how do
you plot say a sine wave in numpy how
what would that look like and so in this
project we wouldn't have to do this
because i've already run these but we'd
want to go ahead and import our numpy as
np and import our matplot library pi
plot is plt so we get our tools going
here and then we'll break it into two
sections because we need our x y
coordinates in here
so first off let's create our x
coordinates
and our x coordinates we're going to set
to an a range
and we want this error a range since
we're doing
sine and cosine it's going to be between
0 and 0.1
and then we use our np and we actually
can look up numpy stores pi so you have
the option just pulling pi in there
directly from numpy it has a few other
variables that it stores in there that
you can pull from there but we have
numpy pi and we generate a nice range
here let's go ahead and run this
and just out of curiosity let's see what
x looks like
i always like to do that so we have
point one point two point three point
four so we're going zero to
in this case nine point four three times
numpy pi remember pi is like three point
something something something so that
makes sense it should be about nine and
we're doing intervals of 0.1 so we
create a nice range of data and then we
need to create our y variable and so y
is going to simply equal np our numpy
dot sine
of x
and then once we have our x and y
and if we print let's go and just print
y
see how that will do this let's do this
so it looks print
x print y
so we basically have two arrays of data
so we have like our x axes and our y
axes going on there
and this is simply a plt dot plot
because we're going to plot the points
and we'll do x comma y
and then we want to actually see the
graph so we'll do plot dot show
and we'll go ahead and run that
and you see we get a nice sine wave and
here's our number zero through nine
and here's our sine value which
oscillates between minus one and one
like we expected to
then for the next challenge
let's create a six by six two
dimensional array and let one and zero
be placed alternatively across the
diagonals
oh that's a little confusing so let's
think about that we're going to create a
six by six
two dimensional so the shape is six by
six two-dimensional array
and let one and zero be placed
alternatively across the diagonals
now if you remember from lesson one we
can fill a whole numpy array with zeros
or ones or whatever so we're going to np
create a numpy zeros and we're gonna do
a six by six and we'll go ahead and make
sure it knows it's an integer even
though it's usually the default and just
real quick let's take a look and see
what that looks like so if i run this
you can see i get
six by six grid so six by six zero zero
zero zero zero
now if i understand this correctly when
they say ones and zero place
alternatively across the diagonals
they want the center diagonal maybe
that's going to stay zero all the way
down
and then the next diagonal will be ones
all the way across diagonally and then
the next one zeros the next one ones and
the next one zeros and so on hopefully
you can see my mouse lit up there and
highlighting it
so let's take a little piece of code
here
and we'll do z
1 colon colon 2 comma colon colon 2
equals 1. and wow that's a mouthful
right there so let's go ahead and run
this and see what that's doing and so
what we're doing is we're saying hey
let's look at in this case row one
there's one and then we're going to go
every other row two so we're gonna skip
a row so skip here skip here skip here
so we're going down
this way and we're going every other row
going this way it's hard to highlight
columns
so you can see right here where the that
we're not touching each row like this
row right here is not being touched okay
so we're going to start with row one and
then we're going to skip a row and
another one and so we're going every two
rows and then in every two rows we're
looking at every two
starting with the beginning that's what
this thing blank means so we're gonna
start with the beginning and we're gonna
look at all of them but we're gonna skip
every two
so starting with row one
we look at all the rows but we do we do
it by two steps so we go one skip one
you know one skip one one skip one one
if you left this out it'd do every one
this would just be ones in fact let's
see what this looks like if i go like
this
and run it
you can see that i guess get ones
so
this notation allows us to go down
each row row by row and we're going to
do every other row
set up on there and so if we're going to
start with row one we also
control z
try that there we go we'll start with
row zero again we're going to go each
row step two so we'll start with row
zero and we'll go every other row
and this time we'll start with one
column one
and again we go every other one going
down
step that's what that step two is and
skipping every other one we're gonna set
that equal to 1. so let's see what that
looks like
and you can see here we get our answer
we get 0 1 0 0 but it has the ones going
in diagonals
on every other diagonal and 0 on every
other one
a little bit of a brain teaser that one
trying to get that one to work out so
you can see how you can arrange your
rows and here's your step and your
different axis on there
and then the next one is
find the total number and locations of
missing values in the array the first
challenge is to create some missing
numbers
so let's create our ray z we're going to
do numpy dot random.rand 10 comma 10
and before we do the second part let me
just take the second part out
and let's just see what that looks like
so let's run that
and there we go so we have a 10 by 10
random array it randomly is picking out
numbers
and
next we want to go ahead and take our
random integer size equals five
and then we're going to do a random
random 10 size equals five
so in the z we're going to select a
number of random spaces here and set
them equal to
null value
and let's go ahead and run that so you
can see what that looks like and if we
look at the array
we've created 1 2
three
four
there should be a fifth one in here my
eyes may be failing me so we've created
a series of out because zero zero to
five zero one two three four so we got
five there are different null values on
here
and
this is kind of a neat notation to
notice that we can generate
random integers size equals five so this
generates
five by five miniature grid inside of
this to tell it where to put the nands
at so that's kind of a cool little thing
you can do
and then we want to look up and see how
many null values are in there
and this is simply just
np is nan of z
simple
so if it is nan that we want to sum it
up so we're going to sum up all of the
different null values on there now let's
do one one more feature in here which is
really cool
let's go ahead and print the indexes so
np arg where np is
nan of z so we're going to create our
own another np array and let's run this
and we'll see here that comes up with
the four indexes
so we did count four of them up there
it tells you where they are one nine two
zero four six five four
and then let's go ahead and run this
again run run there we go this time i
got five that's what good for random
numbers another fun one
that i always like to do it's very
similar because we have n p is nand z
dot sum so we're summing the number of
nands and we can get the indexes and you
can reshape the indexes but you can also
just do we'll do an inds where np is n
of z
and let's just print
let's print that
print
inds let's see what that looks like
and it's very similar we have we have
zero one three zero six three eight six
nine three
but i've split it into two different
arrays so we have our x and our y kind
of coordinates going there and what i
can now do is i can now do z
i n d s
equals and at this point you can also
instead of getting the sum you can get
the means or the all the numbers and
that kind of thing or the average as it
is so that'd be one thing you could do
and you could pick up the average that's
very common in data science to get the
average and just use that for a value
but we're going to set it to zero and
then let's go ahead and print our z
and run that
and you can see we come down here
we have wherever there was a null value
it is now
zero and you can set this whatever you
want this is another way to replace data
or help clean data
depending on what it is you're doing
so wow we covered a lot of stuff so
quick rehash going over everything we
went into there we looked at array
manipulation changing the shape
how to switch that around we even had
the flattened down there which remember
we have another command lower that's
similar we could change the order by f
remember f stands for fortran very
strange connotation but there's c and f
c is the standard and f switches it to a
different order
to be honest i usually have to look it
up because i almost never use f but when
you need it you're like oh my gosh it
was the other order let's do a quick
google so we talked about reshape making
sure that the dimensions are the same
you don't want to have like something
that has 12 objects in it and reshape it
to
c 11 and 5 because it doesn't work it
doesn't divide into 12. we can transpose
so we can switch them so we can go from
a four by three to a three by four oops
i did it the other way around
three by four to four by three
we covered reshaping the array we did
the roll the axes you can do some weird
things with swapping and rolling axes
and transposing the numbers
we dug a little bit into the arithmetic
so we talked about
adding we talked about subtracting
multiplying dividing
and you know at this point it's so
important we just look up the numpy
mathematics and you can see here they
have just about everything your
trigonometry
uh your hyperbolic functions roundings
sums products differences
there are so many all your different
miscellaneous mathematical connotations
so you know google it go to the main
numpy page and look at the different
setups you can do on there
so we covered that
and we did slicing let us break it apart
we did iterating over the array
we covered
joining arrays and how to concatenate
remember concatenate just means add on
to it so in this case how are you adding
b onto a is how you read that from linux
you should catch the concatenate
because that's used regularly there
splitting the array we talked about how
to split the array in different ways so
you can split it in
array of arrays all kinds of different
ways to split the array up how to resize
it and remember resize does not have to
have the same shape
but if you resize it
it will take the data and begin at the
beginning and add new rows on if the
size is bigger if it's smaller it
truncates it it just cuts the end off
we looked at how to do a histogram and
how to plot that
we mentioned
buckets or bins as they call them in
pipelot and then we covered a lot of
other useful functions in numpy talked
about the line space setup for doing
numbers in a series
how to sum the axes up again that's part
of the mathematical formulas there that
we looked at there's a sum there's also
means and median all of those you can
compute in numpy
and you can also do the square root and
standard deviation
the ravel function very similar to the
flat
to be honest i almost always just use
the flat but you know the ravel has its
own kind of functionality that it does
and then we went into some numpy
practice examples we challenged you to
create a sine wave in numpy and how to
do that we're kind of looking for that a
range remember how we do the a range and
you can
have your beginning value your n value
which they did is three times pi and
number pi
and we're going to do intervals of 0.1
and then y just equals the numpy sign of
x there's our math from the math page we
were just looking at remember that it's
right at the top
and uh finally we went down here we had
this kind of a little brain teaser how
to do diagonal zeros and ones
playing with the different connotations
of z of the numpy array
and then we did a random size and we
played a little bit with how to with the
null values playing with null values
if you're doing any data science you
know null values are like a headache
what do you do with them big sets of
data you get rid of them small debt sets
of data you have to factor something in
there like figure out the average or the
median there and then replace it with
that
so with that we want to go and wrap this
up and i want to thank you for joining
me today again my name is richard
kirschner with the simply learn team
that's www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead and if you do
have additional questions feel free to
come visit us on our website or post
some questions down in the youtube video
and we'll follow up with you again thank
you for joining us and happy learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here